RIGHT THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PRVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BIRDS AS A
PATIENT FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIEW THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THIS
TERM AS A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE ROOM MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THE CONNECTIONS MUTED WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE- STREET
BUILDING ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO COME TO ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM AND BEGINNER HEARING
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA THREE ARE ON CONSENT THE
BILLS ON CONSENT OUR ITEM FIVE
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE ITEM NINE
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND
ITEM ELEVEN SB TEN FIFTY SEVEN
ALL RIGHT- WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
SENATOR PAN. PLEASE PROCEED.
YEAH THEY'RE YOU KNOW THEY'RE
ALL A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
MORNING AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CENTER MORNING. SOME
PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU S. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE WHICH
WOULD ENSURE PARENTS KNOW WHAT
COBIT SPREAD LOOKS LIKE IN
SCHOOL SO THEY CAN MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR CHILD AND
THEIR FAMILIES. SPECIFICALLY SB
FORTY NINE SEVENTY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE SCHOOLS TODEVELOP A
COVERT NINETEEN TESTING PLAN
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BAR PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE ENSURES THAT SCHOOLS
PRE SCHOOLS AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND CHILD CARE CENTERS
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THE TESTING PLANTS. C. PAGE HAS
WORKED THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
FUTURE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
GOOD TESTING GUIDES TO SUPPORT
BUT THERE'S CURRENTLY NO
REQUIREMENT FOR A PLAN WELL PLAN
IN PLACE SCHOOL SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MAY LEAVE PARENTS IN
THE DARK. PARENTS SHOULD LET
PARENTS NOT SCHOOLS SHOULD LET
PARENTS KNOW THAT THERE ARE POP
OF CODE CASES JUST LIKE THEY DO
WAY AND THEIR CHILD EXPOSED
OTHER TRANSMISSIBLE CONDITIONS
FOR EXAMPLE I CAN PLACE. WHEN
WELL VACCINES ARE GREATEST
WEAPONS AGAINST. THE PARTICULAR
GETS COVER NINETEEN WE NEED
ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE
THAT FUTURE SCHOOL CLOSURES CASE
SEARCHES. AND PARENTS ARE WELL
INFORMED SO WE NEED TO STOP THIS
. COBIT NINETEEN POSES SERIOUS
HEALTH RSKS TO CHILDREN
ACTUALLY SCHOOLS STUDENTS. HAVE
BEEN NINETEEN RANKS AMONG THE
TOP TEN LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH
WERE AGES FIFTY FIVE TO FOURTEEN
OF FOURTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD BETWEEN JANUARY AND MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN FACT OVER
A THOUSAND CHILDREN AGES
SEVENTEEN AND UNDER HAVE DIED OF
KOBE IN NINETEEN. BUT THAT
PERSPECTIVE APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED KIDS DIED OF
CANCER EVERY YEAR WE MUST NOT
DISMISS THE EFFECTS OF COBIT IN
CHILDREN. FURTHER WE KNOW
TESTING HELPS PREVENT SCHOOL
CLOSURES BRAG SCHOOL CLOSURES
HAVE TAKEN A SIGNIFICANT TOLL ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF STUDENTS PARENTS AND TEACHERS
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS. SO
SCHOOL OPENING AND CLOSURES.
MUST HAVE CONCRETE TESTING PLANS
TO ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE IN PERSON LEARN.
THE SAFE IN PERSON LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. FINALLY SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE WOULD SURE THAT THE
COPA NINETEEN TESTING EQUITY.
ACROSS THE STATE PROVIDING
ENSURING THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO TESTING AND PROVIDING
BETTER DATA FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS EQUITY IN TESTING ALSO
ALLOWS FOR BETTER PARENTAL
TRANSPARENCY BEGAN PARENTS HAVE
A RIGHT TO KNOW THEIR CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO A SERIOUS
DISEASE. SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO STAY OPEN AND HELP
PREVENT FUTURE SURGES A COVE IN
NINETEEN. WE ASK FOR AYE VOTE AT
TWO WITNESSES PRESENT TO US AND
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT GREAT THANK
YOU CENTER PAN ALL RIGHT LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE. PAULA VIA THE VS
GAS AND WE ALSO HAVE ABIGAIL
STODDARD IN GREAT THAT YOU'RE
BOTH HERE IN PERSON- PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND BEGIN YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR. MY NAME IS PAULA
VAZQUEZ AND I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. I'M A PROUD SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER AND THE SAN JUAN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I'M HERE ON
MY OWN BEHALF. AS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER I UNDERSTAND TRUST THAT
PARENTS PLACE IN SCHOOLS TO KEEP
THEIR CHILDREN SAFE. I ALSO
UNDERSTAND VERY CLEARLY THAT
COVERT NINETEEN. CAN BE A
SERIOUS DISEASE ESPECIALLY IN
CHILDREN. THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN KEEPING
SCHOOLS OPEN. KEEPING STUDENTS
LEARNING AND RETAINING THE TRUST
OF THE FULL SCHOOL COMMUNITY ARE
THOSE WITH PLANS TO TEST FOR
COVERT NINETEEN. SAN JUAN
UNIFIED WAS AMONG THE FOR LARGE
DISTRICTS TO HAVE CODES. WILL
CITE. THIS EARNED US THE TRUST
OF PARENTS WHO KNEW. THAT WE
TOOK THE SAFETY OF THEIR
CHILDREN SERIOUSLY. ONCE WE
RETURNED IN PERSON LEARNING. OUR
ATTENDANCE RATE NEVER DIPPED
BELOW SEVENTY PERCENT. WHEREAS
IN MANY OTHER SCHOOLS ATTENDANCE
DIPPED BELOW FIFTY PERCENT.
HAVING SCHOOL TESTING PLANS AND
RESOURCES IS A KEY TOOL TO
MAINTAINING IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION SAFELY. AND WILL
CURB THE SPREAD OF COVERED
NINETEEN IN OUR COMMUNITIES. IN
FACT A REPORT OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
FOUND THAT ONSITE RAPID COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING CONTRIBUTED TO
THE SAFETY OF IN PERSON LEARNING
AND BUILD CONFIDENCE IN SCHOOL
SAFETY FOR PARENTS AND STAFF.
90% OF PARENTS FELT MORE
CONFIDENT HAVING THEIR CHILL
CHILD RETURNED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE OF CODE
TESTING PROGRAMS AT THEIR
CHILD'S SCHOOL. AND 87% OF
PARENTS REPORTED THAT COVERT
TESTING AT THEIR CHILD'S SCHOOL
HELPS KEEP THEIR FAMILY SAFE. IN
SCHOOLS WITH WEEKLY TESTING IN
SCHOOL TRANSMISSION WAS REDUCED
BY AS MUCH AS FIFTY PERCENT. AND
PARENTS CONFIDENCE IN SCHOOL
SAFETY WAS INCREASED. I'M
THANKFUL TO DR PAM AND THE
LEGISLATIVE VACCINE WORKGROUP
FOR MARSHALLING THE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT. OPEN AND SAFE SCHOOLS
FOR KIDS AND STAFF DURING THE
PANDEMIC I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT UP WE GO TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR LEYVA
HERE LEYVA HERE OTRO A VOGUE. A
TROUBLED HERE CORTESE. VALLEY
VALLEY HERE GLAZER. MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HERE EXCELLENT THANK YOU
MA'AM CONSULTANT ART WE WILL
PROCEED AND YOU ARE ABIGAIL
STODDARD PLEASE PROCEED YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ABIGAIL
STODDARD. I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF GOVERNMENT PUBLIC
PROGRAMS A PRIMARY HEALTH.
PRIMARY BEGAN AS A VOLUNTEER
EFFORT SERVING THE COMMUNITY OF
BELIEVE. YEAH IN THE EARLY DAYS
. SINCE THEN OUR TEAM HAS BEEN
DEPLOYED TO SERVE FOR CAL. TO
MAINE BUT IT'S A DELAWARE AND
TOGETHER WE'VE DELIVERED IT
NEARLY TEN MILLION COBRA TESTS
NATIONWIDE. I'M HERE TODAY TO IN
SUPPORT OF SENATORS PAN BILL SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE. OF IT I'M
NOT HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT MY
COMPANY ANY TESTING TECHNOLOGY
LAB CAPACITY OR TREATMENTS.
TODAY ONLY ONE IMPRESSED UPON
THE COMMITTEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PREPAREDNESS AND PLANNING FOR
SCHOOLS STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
OF MY NO MY TIME TODAY IS SHORT
SO I'LL ILLUSTRATE MY POINT WITH
ONE SINGLE TREND. THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOLS IN ROLLING IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH RAPID
TESTING PROGRAM OVER THE PAST
TWELVE MONTHS. IN THE FALL OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL YEAR WE
HAD ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
SCHOOLS IN OUR RAPID TESTING
PROGRAM. IN A FEW SHORT MONTHS
HOWEVER THE PROGRESSION OF THE
DELTA VARIANTS AND EMERGENCE OF
THE OMICRON VARIANT. FLIP THE
SWITCH FOR MANY SCHOOLS FROM NO
TESTING PLAN TO NEEDING TO
IMMEDIATELY ENROLL IN A PLAN IN
ORDER TO AVOID CLOSING THEIR
DOORS. WHEN CONCEPT WITH THE
PEAK. SEARCH AND MAP. CPA SCHOOL
INDUSTRY STAFF WERE FURIOUS TO
ENROLL OVER FIVE HUNDRED BRAND
NEW SCHOOLS IN THE SHORT MONTHS
OF DECEMBER ALONE. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A COVERT
PROGRAM RELIES ON TRUST
COMMUNICATION AND COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT SCHOOLS
AND FAMILIES. OUR SCHOOL TEAMS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PULL OFF A
HERCULEAN EFFORTS THIS YEAR
RESPOND AND PREVENT SCHOOL
CLOSURES BUT THE CYCLE IS SIMPLY
NOT SUSTAINABLE. I'M HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPIDERS BUILD%
TO BREAK THIS CYCLE OF ZERO TO
SIXTY THAT EXACERBATES A STATE
OF CRISIS AND PUTS THE HEALTH OF
SCHOOL COMMUNITIES AT RISK. A
SIMPLE RESPONSE PLAN PUT IN
PLACE BEFORE IT IS NEEDED AND
COMMUNICATED TO STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND PARENTS IS AN
INVESTMENT IN THE PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH. OF FAMILIES.
THANK THANK YOU ARE YOU WILL NOT
TO SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED FEW IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
AND YOUR SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
ENSURE JUST AND PASS ON BEHALF
OF THE LOOKS IN SUPPORT THAT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CENTER
BARRERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING TERRY MEMBERS LIZ FENTON
ON BEHALF OF CONCENTRIC BIKING
CO HERE IN SUPPORT. MY NAME IS
ALLISON LEE I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF PROTECT US IN STRONG SUPPORT
. HELLO MY NAME IS KELLY K. ON
BEHALF PROTECT IS A VAULT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED LET'S GO
TO OUR PHONE LINES WE'RE GOING
TO LIMIT TESTIMONY ON BOTH SIDES
TO FIFTEEN MINUTES IF ONE SIDE
USES LESS THAN FIFTEEN THE OTHER
SIDE STILL GETS THE FULL
FIFTEEN. BUT WE HAVE A BUSY
HEARING TODAY SO WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO BE AS EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE. MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE LINES WAS
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR IN SUPPORT OF IT THE
FOURTEENTH SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
YOUR SUPPORT- SB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY WE'LL GO TO LINE A FORTY
THREE YEAR LIGHT IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JENNIFER I FROM THE CITY OF OUR
MONEY AND I'M CALLING YOU HOME.
THE AVAIL FOR SB ONE FOUR SEVEN
NINE THANK YOU MAY I WE ARE ON
WE ARE DYING ST PORT RIGHT NOW
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO'S IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M APPALLED
AT THE- ON THE PHONE OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT REVITALIZED ONE FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU HAVE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TRYING TO
CALL THROUGH TO OPPOSE YOU DID
NOT ALLOWED- COMMENT AGAIN AND
THEN THE PERSON MEDIA MAY HELP
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JOSH DUGGAR
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT TO VOTE
ONLINE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NOT THAT FAR
YOU KNOW I'M A MEDICAL STUDENT
AT THE DAVID GEFFEN SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AT UCLA IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
. THANK YOU FOR LINE ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS NICOLE MADERA I WORKED
AT THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
AND I'M THE PARENT OF STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND I'M
PORTING STRONGLY AFTER A
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU
FOR LINE ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LEON. WOULD PROTECT US AND WE
ARE ON STRONG STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE. THANK
YOU KNOW THE LINE ONE OF FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
FRANCISCO ALMOST NOTHING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE CALLING
THEM VERY STRONG SUPPORT FOR.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR LINE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
OPPOSE. BOTH LINE UP FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. R. I'M
STILL WAITING TO BE UP TO THE
CABLE SIDE WELL IT BE UP NEXT
MA'AM THOSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
THE MANAGER WE HAVE NOT FOR THE
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THAT TIME GREAT
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR OKAY
WE ARE NOW GOING TO OPPOSITION.
LEADER OPPOSITION WE HAVE
JONATHAN ZUCKER SON AND CRISTINA
HILDEBRAND I BELIEVE BOTH OF
YOU'RE HERE IN PERSON SO PLEASE-
COME TO THE MICROPHONE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. I THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME. HI MY NAME IS JONATHAN
SACRISTAN FOUNDER OF REOPEN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS REPRESENTING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES OF
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. IF TESTING
PLANS HELP SCHOOLS TO STAY OPEN
THE DEBATE WOULD BE SOLELY
FOCUSED ON IF IT'S WORTH THE
COST DESPITE THAT CLAIM FROM THE
AUTHOR TESTING AT SCHOOL DOES
NOTHING AT BEST ACTUALLY KEEPS
KIDS. OUT OF SCHOOL. SUPPORTERS
OF THIS BILL POINT TO A TESTING
CITY OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
SCHOOLS. OVER A YEAR AGO. THAT'S
STUDY SIMPLY SHOWS HOW SAFE IN
PERSON SCHOOL IS. IN THE STUDY
THE POSITIVITY RATE WAS NEARLY
TWO TENTHS OF 1% READER IN THE
LOS BRITAIN SCHOOLS AND HOW
LITTLE VALUE. ROUTINE TESTING
HAS. THERE'S NO CONTROL GROUP
AND THERE IS NO INDICATION
TESTING HELPER TO SPREAD IN
SCHOOLS. WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
SCHOOL SURVEILLANCE TESTING
PROGRAMS INCREASE CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM. L. A. U. S. T. TEST
EVERY STUDENT STAFF WEEKLY. THE
L. A. TIMES RECENTLY REPORTED
HALF OF ONLY USD STUDENTS WERE
CHRONICALLY ABSENT THE SCHOOL
YEAR. LARGELY DUE TO LAUSD IS
TESTING AND QUARANTINE POLICIES.
THEIR PROGRAM COST FOUR TIMES
ORIGINAL BUDGET OF FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION. IN THESE TYPES
OF PROGRAMS COST OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND TO IDENTIFY A SINGLE
POSITIVE TEST RESULT. AND WOULD
COST ABOUT SIX BILLION STATEWIDE
MUCH MORE THAN THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION REQUESTED. ALMOST
EVERY STAKEHOLDERS. IS NOT
SUPPORTING THIS BILL WITH NO
SUPPORT FROM TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ADMINISTRATOR
ASSOCIATION. IN THE MIDDLE OF
NEXT YEAR. AND WOULD. RE
INTRODUCE CHAOS. THAT'S
IMPORTANT HIGHLIGHTS THIS IS A
NEW REQUIREMENT NOT CURRENTLY IN
PLACE. MOST SCHOOLS DO NOT COME
CLOSE TO WHAT IS IN THE CURRENCY
PH TESTING GUIDANCE BECAUSE ONE
IT IS NOT REQUIRED. AND TO WOULD
BE INCREDIBLY BURDENSOME. THIS
IS STATED IN THE BILL ANALYSIS.
IF PASSED WILL BE REQUIRED TO
HAVE PLANS QUOTE CONSISTENT WITH
GUIDANCE FROM CDPH AND QUOTE.
WHAT IS IN THE CURRENT GUIDANCE
FOR ONE SCHOOLS HAVE TO TEST
SOME KIDS AS MUCH AS TWICE A
WEEK. SEEPAGE COULD CHANGE THE
GUIDANCE AT ANY TIME GIVEN
SCHOOLS AND FAMILIES MORE
WHIPLASH ON TOP OF THAT THIS
BILL REQUIRES EACH. HER HIRE AT
LEAST ONE ADDITIONAL STAFF. THE
RESOURCES TO FUND THIS BILL
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER SPENT ON
OTHER PROGRAMS. NEW SOME
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THE STATE
WOULD BE TERMINATED ITS CONTRACT
WITH CITIES TESTING LAB. YES
THIS BILL MOVES IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION CREATING AN INDEFINITE
TESTING PLAN. REQUIREMENTS JUST
YESTERDAY THE CDC ANNOUNCED
THREE IN FOR USE OF ALREADY HAD
GO. OUR SCHOOLS ARE NOT INVOLVED
TO THIS EXTENT ANY OTHER ENDEMIC
ILLNESS. EITHER SHOULD THEY WITH
COVERT NOW THAT IT ENDEMIC LET
OUR SCHOOLS. GET BACK TO
FOCUSING ON EDUCATION WITH THAT
I ASK YOUR NOBLE WHY SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT NEXT WITNESS WE HAVE
CHRISTY HILDEBRAND IS CRISTINA
HELLO CRISTINA IS PROCEDURE OF
TWO MINUTES THANK YOU. MY NAME'S
KRISTINA HOLD AROUND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE BOISTEROUS
ADVOCACY AS WELL AS EDUCATE
ADVOCATE. WELL WE AGREE WITH THE
BILL ANALYSIS THAT SCHOOL
CLOSURES HAVE TAKEN A HUGE TOLL
ON MENTAL HEALTH THROUGHOUT
COULD NINETEEN TENEMENT. WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
REQUIRING BLANKET COULD NINETEEN
TESTING IN SCHOOLS IS NOT
CURRENT SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS.
CURRENCY PH GUIDANCE STATES THAT
THOSE EXPOSED TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN SHOWING NO SYMPTOMS. DO
NOT NEED TO QUARANTINE. THIS
WITH THE SHORT INCUBATION TIME.
OKAY TEST. INSTEAD SCHOOL SHOULD
BE THE H. POLICY OF IF YOU SICK
HOME TO QUITE JUST A FEW
RENOWNED DOT MONICA GANDHI
ASSOCI DIVISION OF AND DISEASES
AT UCSF DR MARTY MARGAERY
PROFESSOR AT JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY OF MEDICINE AS WELL
AS THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OF
PHILADELPHIA WHERE THE
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERT IN VIROLOGY AND
IMMUNOLOGY DR PAUL OFFIT
TEACHERS ALL AGREE THAT MASS A
SYMPTOMATIC TESTING OF SCHOOLS
IS FEW TILE COSTLY AND A BAD USE
OF LIMITED HEALTHCARE RESOURCES
AND SHOULD BE DISCONTINUED. DR
TRACY BETH HOPE A UC DAVIS
EPIDEMIOLOGIST WITH A RESEARCH
FOCUS ON SCHOOL CODE THE
TRANSMISSION AND DOCTOR RUN TO
SAFETY OF PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY
MEDICINE PHYSICIAN AT STANFORD
HEALTH STATE DESPITE ADOPTING A
LARGE SCRIPT SCALE SCHOOL
TESTING PROGRAM CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS MISSED MORE DAYS OF
SCHOOL AND GENERATE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND STUDENTS IN
ARIZONA FLORIDA AND TEXAS BUT NO
ESTABLISHED BENEFIT TO STUDENT
OR COMMUNITY HEALTH. SO WHILE WE
AGREE WITH THESE AROUND RENOWNED
ACTS BUT AND OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE SEEM
LEGISLATURE SEEMS INTENT ON
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD WE ASK
YOU TO OPPOSE THE BILL TODAY BUT
IF YOU VOTE TO MOVE THIS BILL
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE WE ASK YOU
ONLY SIR WITH THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS MAKE THE COULD BE
TESTING PLAN VOLUNTARY AND NOT
REQUIRED. ALLOW SCHOOLS TO REFER
TO LOCAL DISTRICT GUIDELINES
RATHER THAN CDPH GUIDELINES
COULD NINETEEN AFFECT AREAS
DIFFERENTLY AT DIFFERENT TIMES
ENSURE THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
AND MEDICAL OR MENTAL CONDITIONS
HAVE ACCESS TO ALTERNATIVE LESS
INVASIVE TESTS AS WELL AS
EXEMPTIONS AND I'M AT A SUNSET
DATE OF SIX MONTHS IN SUMMARY
WELL WE ASK YOU TO LISTEN TO THE
EXPERTS AND OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE IF YOU FEEL THE
NEED TO VOTE TO MOVE THIS BILL
TODAY WE ASK YOU TO DO SO ONLY
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
COME FORWARD STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ALL
. RACHEL CASE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. I JUST ENERGY MY NAME
IS VERONICA I'M A FOURTH
GENERATION NATIVE CALIFORNIA AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN
SO YEAH THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL THE FUNKY FATHERS AND
ALSO THE WHO OWNS YOUR BODY
DOESN'T WHO OWN YOUR BODY AT THE
WHO OWN YOUR BODY THEN YOU DON'T
OWN YOUR BODY AND THAT MAKES YOU
A SLAVE ORGANIZATION AND I DON'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
BUT A ROGERS FROM CALIFORNIA
PARENTS UNITED REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS IN THE
STATE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. FOR ITS THING NO ONE ELSE
HERE IN OPPOSITION WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES WE WILL DO
FIFTEEN MINUTES OF TESTIMONY IF
WE NEED THAT MUCH TIME- OF
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANYONE WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT THE VISION OF SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION UP AT THE. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN DO YOU HAVE WITH THEM
YOU. HI MY NAME IS K. PRACTICE
AND THE MOTHER AND WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S TO PEOPLE WHEN I
STRONGLY THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MY NAME IS LAURIE FINA I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF DAVE OUR
CINEMA FROM THE NUMBER COUNTY
CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THE TESTING
DNA AND- CURRENT CHINA. THANK
YOU. NEXAVAR LINE ONE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS LORRAINE I'M CALLING FROM
RIVERSIDE AND I'M CALLING ALSO
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA UNITED. I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION THE
FOURTEENTH SEVENTY NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN DO YOU
HAVE A SOME YOU YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE NEXT TO LINE SEVENTY
THROUGH YOUR LIGHT IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JANA AND FROM GRANADA
HILLS CALIFORNIA I AM THE PARENT
OF MULTIPLE CHILDREN AND L. A.
U. S. B. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE STOP
LINING YOUR POCKETS. THANK YOU
NEXT TO THE LINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M
CHRISTY DEPOSITED BURKE HIT WITH
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ACROSS THE LINE
SIXT TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KRISTY LOVELL I'M A- AND I HAD
OVER TWO DECADES OF WORK IN
PUBLIC HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXOBRID LINE ONE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ROBERT SO.
THEN OF DISTRICT ELEVEN SPECIAL
NEEDS ON STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL NO ONE IS ABLE TO SWAP
THANK YOU NOTE THAT THE THANK.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN HERE LIES
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
SAYS GREGORY DION THE VOLUNTEER
WITH CALIFORNIA FREEDOM THE
FIRST AND I WILL CLOSE THE STUFF
. THANK YOU TO LINE ONE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN BUT. ONE ONE
TWENTY YOU HAVE A FROM YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY THAT COULD GO
TO LINE ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HIRING HIM AND THE
MOTHER THE GRANDMOTHER LIVED IN
CALIFORNIA MY WHOLE LIFE AND
I'VE- STRONGLY THIS BILL TO GIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXAVAR IS
A LINE OF THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M
KATHLEEN EGBERT REMINDING YOU
THAT YESTERDAY'S NEWS REPORTED
TO CDC THANK YOU MA'AM YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION NEXT CALLER PLEASE
ALREADY HAVE. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. ONE NINE SIXTY A LINE IS OPEN
. ALL RIGHT. I'M SORRY YOU HAVE
TO RE QUEUE UP LINE SIXTEEN
NOTES WILL GO TO LINE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN'T. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS ALYSSASONORA AND WITH
LOS ANGELES EDUCATORS AND
PARENTS UNITED AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS LONG TERM TESTING DR
PAN YOUR DIET YOU'RE NOT YOU
NEXT HOUR PLEASE. WE'LL TO LINE
UP ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS TRACY BRUCE I HAVE
USED SCHOOL CHILDREN IN THE
POTENTIAL LINDA SCHOOL DISTRICT
I STRONGLY OPPOSE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE JUST TODAY WHILE
WE'RE ON THE PHONE DOCTOR FOSTER
THANK YOU FOR OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR THE LINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS SANAN PRIMARY WITH THAT
OBVIOUSLY I'M ALSO IF THAT'S
WHAT PARA LEGAL WHO HAS FOR
PLANES IN OUR U. S. B. BEANS AND
I AT THE IN RIGHT NOW. PLEASE OF
THEMSELVES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE OF FOR EIGHT LINE OF OPEN.
I AM IN FOR I AM A PARENT TWO
BILLS PEMBREY COUNTY SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND I SAW OPPOSES THE
- THANK YOU TO GO LINE ONE FORTY
NINE NEARLY IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
DR NOW ON THE PLAY. LOOK IN SOME
I STRONG OPPOSE YOUR BILL OR
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN CLEANUP NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WHY TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS NICOLE YEAH AND
THE COUNTY CHAPTER CHAIR OF MY
LOOK I READ THE OVER TWO
THOUSAND FAMILIES IN THE PAST
THE COUNTY AREA. AND SURROUNDING
AREAS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS NADIA
NADIA AND I'M IN IT I HAVE TWO
CHILDREN AND THE SANTA MONICA
SCHOOL. AND I'M A DEMOCRAT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU NEXT ONE
LINE IS SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KATHERINE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
DINO MARTENS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE FELT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS RHONDA
MORGAN AND I OPPOSE SB. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU LINE AT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SALLY I'M A
GRANDPARENT L. UFT AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL I WONDER WHERE HOW CAN
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK TO
GO TO LINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS OLENA AND THE MOTHER OF
MULTIPLE CHILDREN IN PLEASANTON
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
BECAUSE THAT IS AND THEN. THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER TO LINE- FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JASMINE SOUTH OF- I WORK WITH
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES I
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
PART OF EARLY IS BEING A STRONG
STRONG WE. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU HAVE A LINE AT
ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. MY NAME IS KATHY WHITE MEN I
AM FROM WINTER CALIFORNIA NINE
AT FAVORS AND I'M AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU LINE
OF FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MY NAME IS DEEPLY AND I AM
A PARENT OF TWO KIDS IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT OF TWO KIDS. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE ONE TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LIBERTY DON I REPRESENT UNITE
ALAMEDA FROM THE MOMENT HILL I
AM FROM LIVERMORE AND WERE
ACCOUNTABLE OF PLAINTIFF IN THE
PLANT IS NOT THERE. I STRONGLY
NEXT TO FILL THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
THE THIRTY THREE YEAR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE BY. HI MY NAME'S
CHRISTIAN LOPEZ STRONGLY OPPOSE
SENATE BILL. FOURTEEN TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU ONE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS BILL DUNLAP
REPRESENT NEWPORT MESA
UNCENSORED WORK I'M VERY MUCH
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS GORDON
BRANDON I HAVE TWO CHILDREN IN
THE INTEGRATED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ONE
FOUR SEVEN NINE AND SO WITH MY
FAMILY. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHY
NOT ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS EILEEN SAILOR
AND I'M CALLING FROM THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY AREA OF IN
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS TYLER NOW ACTUALLY
BROWN- PARENTS FOR CALIFORNIA
THREE CHILDREN IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE A ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINDSEY
FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AND A
TWO THIRDS MOTHER I OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND SENATOR PM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXAVAR LINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE FORTY THREE. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER COLLINS FINAL I
AM A MOTHER OF A FIVE YEAR OLD
IN THE VALLEY MIDDLE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THEY HAVE BEEN DOING A
QUICK THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE IS SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS GINO THERE AGAIN WITH A
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY I'M
ALSO A REGISTERED DEMOCRAT
REPRESENTING. HUNDREDS OF OTHER
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT WITHIN MY
OWN CIRCLE THANK FORMALLY OPPOSE
S. B. THANK YOU BUT A LINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME'S EMILY CRAIG AND THE
MOTHER OF FOUR AND A STRONG WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CAROL BECAUSE
DANTE I OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR TWO
REASONS THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CAMERA AFTER
NURSE WHEN I OPPOSE THIS BILL IS
EVIL THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA BOTTLE LINE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S
MELISSA DECLARE I'M A MOM TO TWO
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA AND ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR UP
TO LIKE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARK SOMEONE
KNOWS I'M A MOTHER AND FROM.
THAT INJURED CHILDREN THE NORMAL
MY MOTHER DIED FROM THE FIGHTERS
I THINK THANK YOU FOR THE NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU FOR GO LINE
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE OF THE. THOROUGHBRED MUST THEMSELVES
OUT. ONE THIRTY SEVEN. ONE
MOMENT HERE. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SORRY I HAD AT
MY NAME IS CAMILLE GOOD HEROES I
AM A MOTHER FROM TIMBRE TO DINO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXAVAR LINE AT ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
ONE THIRTEEN YOU ARE BECAUSE I
HAD. MY NAME IS GENET MEMBER OF
STAND UP SACRAMENTO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I AM A STUDENT AT OUR
GATE HE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE BILL YOUR PCR TEST DON'T
WORK THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OVER LINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE NEED TO
GENER IN A STRONG SUPPORT I'M
SORRY STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO UP TO LINE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JANET GREEN FROM OVERLAND THAT
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LIFE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CINDY BROADHEATH CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN'T. OKAY THANK YOU SORRY
SO I AM MY NAME IS THAT ASSEMBLY
BROADHEADS I'M A MEMBER FOR AT
STANFORD FRIEDMAN HURT THE
VALLEY I AM A NURSE AND I'M A
MOTHER OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THIRTY NINE FIFTY
THROUGH YOUR LINE IS OPEN JUST A
HEADS UP REPORTS. ONE MARYLAND
YES GO AHEAD SORRY. OKAY AREN'T
MY NAME IS KAREN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MY- MYSELF AND MY
HUSBAND AND THOUSAND PARENTS YOU
CAN GET THE COUNTY I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN. THAT WILL- BETTER AND
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT RIGHT NOW
AND- I STRONGLY OPPOSE- FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE DO NOT
PASSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE LINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING
MR THAT ONE IS NOT INVOLVED.
MOUNTAIN VIEW FOR STRUCTURE
WHICH FOR AND TWELVE OF POLLS SB. TO NINE. THANK YOU AND THAT
WAS ACTUALLY PER TIMING WE JUST
OUR FOR MINUTES MATAMATA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WE WERE BRING
IT TO THE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SENATOR
BOOK HELLO SENATOR PAN AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SO YOU'VE BEEN
THE COVERED- NINETEEN- SENATOR I
WITH YOUR MD AND SO FORTH FIRST
OFF THANK YOU FOR. CALLING THE
OTHER TWO BILLS THAT HAVE
BECAUSE A LOT OF- COMMOTION AND
IF YOU CREDIT FOR THAT ON THE ON
THE SPRINT ON THIS ONE COMING
FROM A SCHOOL PERSPECTIVE- I DO
HAVE A XIN. AND- THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT THE L. A. L. E. AS
TO DESIGNATE ADDITIONAL STAFF TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL AND REPORT ON ITS COVERT
NINETEEN TESTING PROGRAM TO THE
CDPH. WITH THE EXISTING STAFFING
SHORTAGES THAT WERE-
EXPERIENCING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AT THIS TIME WILL AT LEAST
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO COMPETE
WITH THESE PROVISIONS WHAT HAVE
BEEN THE FEEDBACK THAT YOU HAVE
RECEIVED FROM OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
NO ACTUALLY. WE ARE FEET
RECEIVING FEEDBACK FOR THAT-
FIRST OF ALL OF COURSE- TESTING
PLANS ARE ACTUALLY VERY
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THE SCHOOLS
OPEN. AND ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE SPENDING A
LOT OF MONEY ACTUALLY OFTEN
COVERT CONTROL ITSELF. AND- UP
FROM THE STAFF YEAH WE ARE
WORKING ALSO ON A FUNDING AND
STATE BUDGET AS WELL AND THAT-
TO HELP SUPPORT SCHOOLS BOTH THE
TESTING AND THE STAFFING THAT
THEY NEED TO CARRY OUT. ITS
THANK FOR PAN AM- I HAD IT HERE
. IN MY IN MY NOTES THAT THE ONE
OF THE CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE
I'D WAS THAT ALTHOUGH THE STATE
HAD IMPLEMENTED OR ALLOCATED TWO
TESTING THE CONCERN THAT YOU HAD
THE NOT ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ACROSS THE STATE HAVE THAT NOW.
THE QUESTION THE CONCERN I HAD
IS OR ACTUALLY WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ARE IS THE
FACT THAT. IF THE CDPH DID NOT
FIND THIS ARE REQUIRED IF THIS
IF DID IN MY END DATE THIS AS A
REQUIREMENT TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THEIR THE CDPH- WHY
DO YOU FEEL COMPELLED TO. MAKE
THIS A MANDATE FOR THE STATE.
WELL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FIRST OF ALL EVERY CHILD HAS A
RIGHT TO AN EDUCATION IT'S IN
THE CONSTITUTION WE ALSO HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN ARE ABLE TO
ATTEND SCHOOL SAFELY. IT'S
IMPORTANT PARENTS ACTUALLY KNOW
THEIR CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED- TO- TO THE SPEAKERS AT
SCHOOL. SO IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
ACTUALLY OUR PARENTS NEED TO BE
INFORMED YOU HAVE PARENTS TO
EITHER CHILD MAY BE VULNERABLE
THEMSELVES- THEY MAY HAVE A
CHRONIC CONDITION LIKE ASTHMA OR
DIABETES- THEY MAY ALSO HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS AT HOME WHO MAY
BE AT RISK RIGHT SO. MAYBE
THERE'S A- A GRANDPARENT AT HOME
OR A BAR OR OTHER OTHER PERSON
AT HOME AND SO IT PARENTS NEED
TO KNOW IF THEIR CHILD GOT
EXPOSED. AND MIGHT BE INFECTED
THAT THEY CAN PROTECT THEIR
HOUSEHOLD AND TO PROTECT YOUR
CHILD THAT'S WHY TESTING PLANS
ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT THAT. WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION. THEY NEED TO KEEP
THEIR- OF THEIR CHILD AND THEIR
HOUSEHOLD SAFE. AND SO TESTING
PLANS ARE IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT. AGAIN THESE ARE TESTING
PLANS CONSISTENT WITH A
CALIFORNIA PART PUBLIC HEALTH
WHICH OF COURSE IS. IT IS IT CAN
BE JUST WILL BE ADJUSTED BASED
ON THE CASELOAD IN THE COMMUNITY
AS WELL SO. I THINK SOMETIMES
PEOPLE PERCEIVE THAT. THE
TESTING PLAN IS GOING TO BE JUST
ONE FIXED PLANNED IT'S ACTUALLY
IT'S A IT'S A DYNAMIC SITUATION
WHICH- WAS REALLY TO THE NEEDS
OF THAT INSURING THAT WE KEEP.
OUR CHILDREN SAFE AND ALSO
COMMITTEE SAFE. BECAUSE THANK
YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CENTER
PAN AS A FORMER SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD MEMBER I'M ALWAYS VERY-
LARRY AND STATE REQUIREMENTS
SPECIALLY WHEN THE CDPH DOES NOT
IRATE I'M JUST GONNA I'M A
LITTLE HESITANT TO BE HONEST AND
I WOULD PROBABLY NOT BE
SUPPORTING ACTION WILL BE
SUPPORT WITHOUT TODAY OKAY HOW
DOES FOR THAT BUT I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT OUR LOCAL SKIP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT PROTOCOLS
THAT AB. THE SENIOR- NEEDED FOR
THEIR REGION OR FOR THEIR FOR
THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT AND- IT'S
NOT AS IF IT'S NOT AVAILABLE FOR
THEM AS WELL AS VACCINES AND SO-
I'M NOT SURE THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY REQUIRED- BUT- I AM
GRATEFUL THAT THE MONEY'S THERE
FOR THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD
WISH TO IMPLEMENT. A PLAN AND I
TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
ALLOW OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS YOU
DECIDE WHAT WORKS BEST. LOCALLY
AND IF THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO NOT- FOLLOW PLANNED
IT SEEMS APPROPRIATE- A LOCAL
PARENTS DISAGREE THEY HAVE THE
OPTION TO ADVOCATE FOR WHAT FOR
WHAT THEY FEEL IS APPROPRIATE
AND NEEDED WITHIN THEIR
DISTRICTS. SO I'M NOT I'M NOT
FRONT AND THE FACT THAT OF THE
IMPACT THAT WILL HAVE LOCALLY
I'M GOING TO. NOT SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY SO- ON THOSE GROUNDS
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING THIS. THANK YOU FELLOW
CENTER DOLLAR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO. FIRST OFF I WANT TO
SAY THAT SOME YOU KNOW I'M
HAVING A TIME UNDER WHY THIS
THIS BILL IS NOT GOING TO BE
SIGNED INTO LAW UNTIL JANUARY
ONE OF THIS THIS IS NOT URGENCY
BILL CORRECT. NO SO. JUST
YESTERDAY I BELIEVE IT IS OR
TODAY YOU KNOW. THE SOUTHEAST
ANNOUNCED THAT WE ARE OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC. OR OR OR AT MOVING OUT
OF PENDING I JUST SAW IT ON CNN
ON MY PHONE NOT WHETHER THAT
HE'S FLIP OR FLOP AND I DON'T
KNOW BUT THE POINT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT- THIS BILL IS NOT
AN URGENCY BILL SO THIS BILL.
BASICALLY GONNA TO COME INTO LAW
IN JANUARY SO WHY IT WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHT PROCESS ON WHY WE WOULD
BE WITH YOU IF WE WERE IF WE
NEED TO TESTING WE WOULD BE
DOING TESTING RIGHT NOW- AND
NOT. AND THEN MOVE IT TO JANUARY
SO THAT IN AND OF I WON JUST
STATE THE FACTS THE PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORTED THIS BILL ALL PEOPLE
THAT. MOSTLY ALL PEOPLE WHO MAKE
THESE TEST. AND ARE PROFITING
OFF OF. THE OF SELLING OF THESE
TEST AND THEY KNOW IF WE'RE IF
WE MANDATED OUR SCHOOLS. THEY'RE
GONNA MAKE MONEY. SO CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS IS ON WHY THIS BILL. IS
NOT SET FOR URGENCY BILL IT IF
WE WERE IN A PANDEMIC RIGHT NOW
WE WOULD NEED TO BE TESTING ARE.
OUR CHILDREN. SO FIRST OF ALL-
CENTER DOLLY THOUGHT THE
RESPECT. THOSE PEOPLE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROFITING. FROM TESTING. AND I
FIND IT DISAPPOINTING THAT YOU
WOULD LEVEL THAT KIND OF
ACCUSATION. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LIST OF SUPPORTERS MOST OF THE
SUPPORTERS VAST MAJORITY OF
SUPPORTERS ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO
WOULD IN ANY WAY PROFIT.
PACKAGES ENOUGH MANY OF OUR
PEOPLE- TALK ABOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WE HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. AND YET YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT THE COST TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT THEY SEE HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. TO KEEP THE
SCHOOLS SAFE TO KEEP THE KIDS
SAFE AND ALSO BECAUSE PARENTS
WANTED. AND WE ALSO OUGHT TO
MAKE NOTE THAT MANY YOUTH
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT THIS BILLS
WELL. SO THE VERY STUDENTS
THEMSELVES SOME OF WHOM OF
ACTUALLY PROTESTED AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WERE ACTING. STRONGLY
ENOUGH- SO I WOULD SET ITSELF I
WOULD SAY IS THAT- FIRST OF ALL
I WOULD HAVE TO STRONGLY
DISAGREE WITH WHAT YOU'VE SAID
THAT CONTENTION. I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT- YES IT WOULD NOT
ACTUALLY- THE BILL ITSELF WOULD
NOT TAKE EFFECT JANET FIRST.
UNTIL J. FIRST TWENTY THREE
WOULD SIGN. PASSED AND SIGNED
THE LAW. HOWEVER THAT DOESN'T I
THINK IT'S- THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WE CAN'T ACTUALLY IN FACT
MANY TIMES WE HAVE BILLS THERE'S
THAT MAYBE SOME IMPLEMENTATION.
TIME AS WELL AND SO WEAK THAT
THERE WOULD BE. THAT TIME FOR
FIRST FOR GUARANTEED TO DO THE
WORK BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT
THAT- THAT. BUT IT WAS BEEN
FOLLOWING KOBE NINETEEN IT IS
ACTUALLY A CREDIBLE. SCIENTISTS
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS THIS IS SAYING
THAT THIS THING'S OVER RIGHT AND
BY THE WAY WHEN YOU SAY
SOMETHING IS ENDEMIC IT DOESN'T
MEAN IT'S OVER EITHER FOR
EXAMPLE POLIO IS ENDEMIC. PRIOR
TO THE- POLIO VACCINE. I WASN'T
EMIC. THAT'S STILL CREATED
PROBLEMS FOR CHILDREN BECAUSE HE
HAD IT FOR FAMILIES BECAUSE YOUR
CHILDREN WHO ARE PARALYZED. AND
EVERY SUMMER PARENTS WOULD LIVE
IN FEAR ABOUT THEIR CHILD
POTENTIALLY BECOMING PARALYZED.
BY THIS VIRUS IS ENDEMIC VIRUS.
RIGHT YOU KNOW RUBELLA WAS
ENDEMIC. BUT IT CAUSED BIRTH
DEFECTS IN PREGNANT WOMEN. RIGHT
SO WE TAKE MITIGATION MEASURES
ACTUALLY BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF THE
DISEASE AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT WELL CERTAINLY TALK TALK
ABOUT DEATH IN MY PRESENTATION
IN FACT TOO MANY CHILDREN HAVE
DIED. OF CALVIN THAT IS NOT THE
ONLY OUTCOME. WHAT WE KNOW NOW.
IS THAT RATES OF DIABETES YOU'RE
OUT AFTER SOMEONE GETS COBIT.
THIS HIGHER. SO YEAH WE DON'T DO
WE WANT MORE CASES DIABETES WE
KNOW RATES OF HEART DISEASE ARE
MUCH HIGHER AFTER SOMEONE GETS
CODED. WE'VE SEEN RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS THAT THERE IS BRAIN
DAMAGE. AND PEOPLE WHO'VE HAD
COATED AND DILATES NOT JUST
SEVERE BECAUSE OF IT IT'S EVEN
MILD COATED. SO LONG COVE IT
OTHER TYPES OF POST CODE
SYMPTOMS THESE ARE IMPORTANT-
THAT WE THINK THAT WE NEED TO OF
COURSE WE NEED FURTHER RESEARCH
TO BETTER DEFINE IT WE HAD A
WHOLE HEARING ABOUT IN THEIR
HEALTH COMMITTEE. BUT I DON'T
THINK ONE WANTS TO BE. YEAH THAT
CASUAL ABOUT THE IDEA THAT.
CHILDREN GETTING INFECTED OR
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS ARE TO HAVE
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSEHOLD.
GETTING INFECTED IS NESTLE GOOD
THING NOW. WHAT THE TESTING PLAN
DOES IS THAT IT HELPS INFORMS.
PARENTS AND FAMILY SO THEY CAN
MAKE THEIR OWN JUDGMENTS. IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY NEED TO DO TO KEEP THEIR-
CHILD AND FAMILY SAFE. BUT IF
THEY DON'T KNOW. THE SCHOOLS
AREN'T HELPING. BECAUSE AFTER
ALL THE CHILD SPENDING TIME TO
SCHOOL BUT THEY DON'T KNOW THE
TALENT BUT AND YOU KNOW AND- YOU
KNOW YOUR PET. I'M A PARENT
RIGHT. I MEAN I GET NOTES FROM
SCHOOL WHENEVER THEY EXPOSE NOT
JUST TO COPE IT BUT THE OTHER.
YOU KNOW TRANSMISSIBLE THINGS
LIKE YOU KNOW YOU MENTIONED EVEN
HEADLIGHTS WHICH BY THE WAY
HASN'T AS FAR AS I KNOW HAS
REALLY TOLD ANYONE. IF YOU DON'T
TELL THE PARENTS THAT THEIR
CHILD EXPOSED HEADLIGHTS THEY
GET UPSET. I USED BY THEIR USED
TO BE A- POSITION I WAS A
PHYSICIAN CONSULTANT FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT BEFORE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. OKAY I MEAN  SAW I
WAS THE PHYSICIAN CONSULTANT FOR
A FOR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
PARENTS WANT TO KNOW. THAT'S
WHAT THEY KNOW THEIR KIDS HAVE
BEEN EXPOSEDTO SOMETHING
CONTAGIOUS. SO THEY CAN MAKE.
SENSE AND SO WHAT THIS TESTING
PLAN REQUIREMENT IS THAT TO BE
SURE PARENTS KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON THEIR KIDS. AND IF THEY'VE
BEEN EXPOSED TO SOMETHING LIKE
COBIT EXPOSE THE COBIT BECAUSE
COVE IT IS A DISEASE THAT MANY
PARENTS TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY AND
THEY SHOULD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PANTHER DOLLY. PUT GO
AHEAD I'M JUST GOING TO LET THE
COMMITTEE- I HAVE TO PRESENT A
BILL IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE RIGHT
NOW I WILL BE OPPOSINGTHE BILL
I DON'T KNOW WE'D BE ABLE TO
TAKE A VOTE RIGHT SOONER WE
PROBABLY DON'T SOMEONE IS GOING
TO MAKE A MOTION. WE WILL DO IT
LATER IN THE DAY SO YOU'LL HAVE
TIME TO VOTE. YOU'RE WELCOME-
CENTER PAMELA TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES BUT PART OF THAT I JUST
WANT TO ASK ONE QUESTION- THE
BILL REQUIRES A TESTING PLAN
RIGHT CORRECT OKAY I THINK
PEOPLE HAVE CONFLATED THAT THE
BILL IS GOING TO REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO MANDATE TESTING. BUT JUST
REQUIRING A PLAN I KIND OF THINK
ABOUT IT AS NGUYEN- THE PANDEMIC
FIRST STARTED AND WE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH PP AND SO NOW WE ARE
REQUIRING HOSPITALS AND NURSING
ASSOCIATIONS AND WHATNOT. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
PROPER PP SO TO ME THIS IS ABOUT
PLANNING IN THE EVENT WE HAVE
ANOTHER PANDEMIC- AND I ALSO
JUST WANTED TO NOTE. ALL THAT
ARE OFF. FROM PEOPLE OPPOSING
THE BILL BUT WE RECEIVE MANY
CALLS AT OUR OFFICE FROM PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT. ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
CALLED IN SUPPORT FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN AND THEY SAID THEY ARE
THEIR PARENTS BECAUSE SOME OF
THEM WERE FIFTH AND SIXTH
GRADERS SO THE PARENTS CALL
THEM. AND THEY SAID THAT THEY
FEEL SAFER AT SCHOOL IF THEY CAN
GET TESTED FIRST THOUGHT THAT
WAS INTERESTING. ALL THE
OPPOSITION CAME FROM THE PARENTS
WHICH I GET IT I HAVE KIDS I
WORRY ABOUT MY CHILDREN TOO. BUT
THAT THE STUDENTS ACTUALLY FELT
THAT THEY WERE SAFER- BEING
TESTED IT MADE THEM COMFORTABLE
GOING TO SCHOOL. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL- JUST SO
EVERYONE KNOWS AS THE CHAIR I
CANNOT MOVE THE BILL- CENTER PAM
IS A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
CANNOT MOVE THE BILL BECAUSE HE-
THEIR OF THE BILL SO WE WAIT
UNTIL WE HAVE A MORE MEMBERS-
AND SEE IF SOMEONE. MOVES THE
BILL SO SENATOR PAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY SO- CENTER PAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I HAVE TO
GO VOTE IN THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE. SO SENATOR PAM I AM
GOING TO ASK YOU TO TAKE OVER.
AND A SERGEANTS IF YOU CAN CALL
OTHER AUTHORS AND ASK THEM TO
COME ON OVER THAT WOULD BE GREAT
. OKAY. OKAY I THINK YOU HAVE TO
RUN ACROSS THE STREET- ALL RIGHT
SO IF YOU HAVE
NOTIFY- OTHER AUTHORS WHO WISH
TO COME AND PRESENT I BELIEVE
NEXT UP MAYBE THE CENTERS AS
CENTER WIENER BOB A CINNAMON.
SO FOR STAFF THEY'RE WATCHING-
IF YOU'RE MEMBER HAS A- BILL-
AND THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AND
THEY WANT TO GET THE
PRESENTATION DONE EARLIER NOW IS
THE TIME.
WE'RE WAITING FOR OTHERS. OKAY
THE COMPANY. SO IN THE NEAR THE
CHAIR VICE CHAIR HERE SO WE GOT
THE WHOLE RUN THE SHOW NOW I.
SERAPH WELCOME WELL. IT'S
EDUCATION CENTER UP WANT TO COME
TO THE SINCE. AND I SEASON
FOURTEEN BEHIND BUT I THINK YOU
ARE STILL FIRST ON YOUR YOUR
FIRST IN THE ROOM AND FIRST ON
THE- AGENDA SO ALL RIGHT- SO
WILL. NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SIX S. B. ELEVEN NINETY NINE BY
CENTER ROCK WELCOME. THANK YOU.
MIKE THANK YOUS THE SUN THANK
YOU SIR. THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
THE REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION TO SECURE AN ACUTE
CARE TEACHING HOSPITAL IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF TRAINING YOU SEE OUR
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE MEDICAL
STUDENTS MEDICAL RESIDENTS AND
MEDICAL FELLOWS. AS SOME MAY
RECALL MAY RECALL THE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE WAS DESIGNED AND
ESTABLISHED FOR BUDGETARY
REASONS IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
. AS A COMMUNITY BASED MEDICAL
SCHOOL WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF A
DEDICATED UC HOSPITAL- MEDICAL
CENTER FOR CLINICAL TRAINING AND
EDUCATION TO MEDICAL STUDENTS
AND RESIDENTS. TO DATE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IN UNDERSTANDING IT
ISTHE ONLY UC MEDICAL SCHOOL TO
OPERATE. WITHOUT A DEDICATED
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER. AS A
RESULT THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IS
RELIED ENTIRELY ON PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITY HOSPITALS
AND CLINICAL FACILITIES IN THE
REGION PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT AND NOT FOR PROFIT. TO
TRAIN ITS STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS
. THIS COMMUNITY BASED TRAINING
PROGRAM WITHOUT A DEDICATED YOU
SEE TRAINING PLATFORM HAS OF
COURSE NOT BEEN OUT BEEN WITHOUT
CHALLENGES. CHALLENGES AND
CONFLICTS RESULTING IN SOME
CASES FROM SOME LOCAL HOSPITALS
TERMINATING YOU SEE SPONSORED.
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO RETAIN
MORE OF THE TRAINING REVENUE
INDOOR TO REGAIN MORE CONTROL
OVER RESIDENT PRODUCTIVITY. IN
OTHER CASES LOCAL HOSPITALS AND
OWN HOSPITAL RESIDENT THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE UNWELL
UNABLE OR UNWILLING TO AUGMENT
OR EXPAND. TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
UC. SCHOOL OF MEDICINE MEDICINE
RESIDENTS ALTHOUGH THIS IS
CERTAINLY CAUSE SOME TURBULENCE
TODAY THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO COPE WITH THIS.
INSTABILITY IN ITS TRAINING
PROGRAM. HOWEVER WITH THE
ONGOING CONSTRUCTION OF UCR'S
NEW ACADEMIC FACILITY WHICH WILL
DOUBLE THE ENROLLMENT OF THE
MEDICAL SCHOOL FROM TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO FIVE HUNDRED
PHYSICIANS IN TRAINING. DOUBLE
THE NUMBER OF MEDICAL STUDENT
CLINICAL ROTATION SLOTS REQUIRED
IN HOSPITAL AND CLINICAL
FACILITIES. INCREASE THE NUMBER
AND CAPACITY OF ASSOCIATED
RESIDENCY TRAINING PROGRAMS. AND
WITH FURTHER GROWTH ANTICIPATED
AS WE HOPE IN THIS MEDICAL
SCHOOL THE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS WILL
RAPIDLY EXCEED THE CAPABILITIES
OR EXISTING LOCAL COMMUNITY
HOSPITALS AND CLINICAL
FACILITIES. THUS IF WE HOPE TO
BEGIN TO SOLVE THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER SHORTAGE IN INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SOME EXTENT
IN THE STATE. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE BEGIN THE PROCESS TO HELP YOU
SEE YOUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
ESTABLISH A STABLE TRAINING
PLATFORM A UC TEACHING HOSPITAL
FOR UCR'S MEDICAL STUDENTS AND
RESIDENTS. SO AT THE APPROPRIATE
POINT TIME I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
AS FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- SERA- A NOTE THAT THERE'S
NO A LEAD SUPPORT- WITNESS-
REGISTERED FOR- TESTIMONY SO
WITH AND JUST MOVE HERE TO ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES- PRESENT WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. A MORTICIAN
POSITION. MISTER MEMBERS CUEVAS
FROM WITH THE K. MAY.
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE THANK YOU. SEEN ON US
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1199% A ROCK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT- SB
ELEVEN NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME RIGHT NOW
MOVES ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AGAIN THERE'S NO
LEGAL OPPOSITION WITNESS-
REGISTERED FOR TESTING. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED. THING NINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AT THE ALADDIN
NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME OKAY WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- I GUESS A
ROCK JUSTA BRIEF QUESTION I
KNOW THAT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S
SOME LOCAL- CONCERNED AT THAT
EXPRESSED IN THE ANALYSIS- WILL
YOU BE WORKING WITH. THE LOCAL
MEDICAL COMMUNITY WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT. CREATION OF A
NEW HOUSE I GUESS THE NEW
HOSPITAL IN THE AREA OF THE
COMMUNITY CERTAINLY YOU KNOW AND
IT'S NOT UNEXPECTED WE SAW THIS
WHEN THE MEDICAL SCHOOL WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE PROBLEM IS AS YOU CERTAINLY
KNOW DR GRANT BECAUSE- RENT
RESIDENCY PROGRAM SO IT'S SORT
OF A- A PUSH AND PULL THE
FINANCIAL ASPECTS THE- THE
MEDICARE DIRECT AND INDIRECT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS AGO IF
IT'S OF SPONSORED PROGRAM YOU
GET IT IF IT'S AFFILIATED YOU
HAVE TO SURE THERE'S- THERE ARE.
CONFLICTS OVER THE SHARING-
TENANTS OF WHICH IS OPPOSED TO
THIS OF COURSE. USE YOUR SCHOOL
MEDICINE USED TO HAVE. RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THAT THE TENET HOSPITAL
AND NO LONGER DOES. INTENT OF
COURSE AT THAT THE TWO YOU'RE A
SERIES OF HOSPITALS HAS A VERY
ROBUST RESIDENCY PROGRAM WHICH-
TENANTS SPONSORS SO. WE'RE GOING
TO WORK WITH- WITH ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES BOTH THE HOSPITALS
AND THE- MEDICAL COMMUNITY TO
TRY TO. MAKE THIS WORK BUT IF
THE SCHOOL IS GOING TO EXPAND
AND GROW. IT NEEDS A STABLE
PLATFORM WITH MORE RESIDENCY
FRANKLY RESIDENT RAM CAPACITY
WHICH COURSE TO TEACH US BUT LET
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. BUT
THIS. IS THE- ACTING AS CHAIR
AND THE ONLY COMMITTEE- WE- WANT
MORE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WILL
TAKE MY- AND- SAID THAT THIS.
TIME SEVENTIES GAS A LITTLE NOW
WANT I NUMBER SO SP. YES WE DO
IT WILL BE JULY. I HAVE A CLOSED
RESPECTFUL AS GONNA AT THE-
POINT THANKS YOU VERY MUCH SIR
OKAY THANK YOU I NEXT. I'M SEVEN
SP FOUR THIRTY THREE AGAIN BY
CENTER ROCK AND THEN WILL COME
NOW. AND I SEE SIR WIENER TO ALL
MOVE TO FEDERAL. IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THAT ITEM- THANK YOU SIR
FOR. OF ME THANK MIKE COLLEAGUE
CENTER WIENER FOR HIS PAY. HERE
MAKE TO QUICK IN THIS. OF
PRIVATE POST SECOND IS. BILL A
SON. BILL SHE THE COMMITTEES
PART. IN THE ON GO DISCUSS ABOUT
THE OPERATION OF THIS BUREAU.
AND LIKE TO THANK MS RUMORS ON.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HER
DEDICATION TO THIS TOPIC AND FOR
THE VERY VERY THOROUGH ANALYSIS
HIGHLIGHTING A NUMBER OF THE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT WE WILL
COLLECTIVELY WORK ON. TO ADDRESS
AND RESOLVE AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
THE BILL TODAY AUTHORIZES ROAD
TO INCLUDE IN ORDER TO
COMPENSATE STUDENTS FOR HARM
THAT RESULTED OR MAY HAVE
RESULTED. FROM AN INSTITUTION'S
VIOLATION IN A CITATION THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES THE BUREAU TO TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS BASED ON THE
SEVERITY OF AN INSTITUTION'S
VIOLATIONS. AND THE HARM THAT
RESULTS OR MAY RESULT TO
STUDENTS FROM THE INSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATIONS. THIS MEASURE BUILT
ON EFFORTS UNDERTAKEN LAST YEAR
AS YOU KNOW DURING THE SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT PROCESS FOR THE
BUREAU AND CHANGES MADE IN A
PRIOR SUNSET BILL. THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO BE THE VEHICLE FOR
ADDITIONAL CHANGES. COMING FROM
OUR AND COLLABORATIVE SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT WORK DURING
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO MOVING
FORWARD THE BILL WILL BE UPDATED
TO REFLECT THE NECESSARY CHANGES
TO ENSURE STUDENT SUCCESS AND
QUALITY EDUCATION INCLUDING MANY
OF THE ITEMS HIGHLIGHTED IN THIS
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS OUR GOAL OF
COURSE IS TO FIND THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE. IN THE NEED
FOR TRANSFERRED REGULATION OF
THE PROGRAMS OFFERING TRAINING
AND EDUCATION TO MOVE TO CAL.
THROUGH AN ACT THAT MAKES SENSE
AND ULTIMATELY YIELDS OUR SHARED
GOALS OF PORTABLE MEANINGFUL
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU THE COMMITTEE WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF THE BUREAU.
SCHOOLS A STUDENTS ON THIS
ESSENTIAL BILL TO GUARANTEE THAT
THE ACT PREVENTS PREDATORY
PRACTICES AND PROMOTES
ADVANCEMENT OF STUDENTS. WHO
ATTEND BUREAU APPROVED
INSTITUTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
POINT IN TIME- I GUESS MISTER
CHAIR ESPECIALLY AS FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU I JUST KNOW
REGISTERED- SUPPORT WITNESSES
FOR TESTIMONY SO WE'LL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED ANY.
SUPPORT HERE- SAME NOT WATER
PLEASE OPEN THE FROM WHO TO
TESTIFY AGAINST OF S. FORTY
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS THE ONE AND
THEN THE OF YOUR SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE NO SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU AND IS- WEEKEND
WE HAVE NO LEAD WITNESS
OPPOSITION- WITNESS- ALSO
REGISTERED TO TESTIFY AS ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. SAYING
NINE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WE SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION- SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS THE ONE AND
THEN THEY OFFER OPPOSITION. AND
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE AND
HAVING HEARD IT AND BE IN P. AND
VOTED FOR THEIR FLANK OF FIND A
VOTE FOR AGAIN BUT I DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS HERE TO MOVE
OUR- VOTE ON IT. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. REGULAR JUSTICE FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
POINT TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. OKAY THANKS FOR MUCH
CENTER ROCK. YOUR PRESENTATION
CENTER WIENER. WELCOME I THINK
YOU HAVE TO BILLS AND OF WILL
TAKE THEM IN ORDER UNLESS YOU
WISH TO DO IT OTHERWISE YEAH
THANK YOU I WILL BE IN A AND
pTHAT HOUSING COMMITTEE IS NOT
THE ONLY GHOST TOWN IN THE
BUILDING TODAY- OKAY WILL BEGIN
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR. AND THANK YOU-
SENATOR OF COURSE YOU SEEN THIS
THIS CALL REPORT AS WE WENT
THROUGH THE HOUSE COMMITTEE-
TODAY I AM PRESENTING SENATE
BILL. NINE SIXTY FOUR- TO HELP
RETAIN AND EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S
STRUGGLING MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE- THIS BILL IS A PIECE-OF THE PUZZLE AND EXPANDING
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT- WE ARE WORKING HARD
TO EXPAND. TO INVEST IN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND TO EXPAND.
INSURANCE COVERAGE OF FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT BUT OF COURSE-
WE NEED. TO HAVE MORE
PRACTITIONERS TO ACTUALLY
DELIVER THAT CARE- JUST ONE
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVING
WITH A MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION
RECEIVE THE CARE THEY NEED- AND
THE SHORTAGE OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IS PART OF
THE PROBLEM- THIRTY ONE COUNTIES
WITH A- NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES REPORT. HAVING A
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. I'M
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AREAS AND
COMMUNITIES- WHERE ENGLISH IS
NOT THEIR FIRST. AND OTHER
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES- WE HAVE A
PARTICULARLY ACUTE- CHALLENGE IN
TERMS OF CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AND AVAILABLE MENTAL HEALTH-
WORKERS- THE SENATE BILL NINE
SIXTY FOUR WILL HELP SHORE UP AN
INCREASE- ACCESS TO CRITICAL
MENTAL HEALTH CARE WITH HOLISTIC
SOLUTIONS. TO REBUILD OUR
WORKFORCE BY- ESTABLISHING A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PRESERVATION AND RESTORATION
FUNDS- TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. FOR THIS WORKFORCE
CREATING A STATEMENT PROGRAM FOR
STUDENTS IN THE MASTER MASTERS
OF SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS. WITH A
SPECIALIZED FOCUS ON PUB PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. CREATING AN
ONLINE JOBS BOARD. A RELATION.
THE CALIFORNIA. JOB OPENINGS FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKERS.
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CARE BY MAKING PEER
SUPPORT SPECIALIST. WITH
STATEWIDE MEDICAL BENEFIT-
INSTEAD OF AN OPT IN AS A PILOT
PROGRAM. AND ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE CERTIFIED IN
CERTIFYING BODY- TO CERTIFIED-
PEER SPECIALISTS. AMENDING THE
EGGS MEDICAID- MET EDUCATION- TO
I'D BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
TO THE LIST OF THOSE ELIGIBLE
UNDER THE PROGRAM. DEVELOPING
XCELERATED SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS
WITH NEW COURSEWORK FOCUSED ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TO GET NEW
AND- BETTER TRAINED SOCIAL
WORKERS INTO THE FIELD QUICKLY.
DEVELOPING AN ACCELERATED
PROGRAM FOR CERTIFICATION- FROM
CERTAIN INCLUDING CERTIFICATION
SOCIUS BOXERS AMASSED PROGRAMS
ARE REQUIRING A STUDY OF
CALIFORNIA'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS TO
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS THAT KEEP
WELL TRAINED AND TALENTED
WORKERS FROM ENTERING THE FIELD
AND WORKING AT THE TOP OF THEIR
SCOPE. OF REQUIRING A
COMPREHENSIVE LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS
OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE A LONG TERM POLICY
CHANGES AND INVESTMENTS ARE
ROOTED IN OUR ACTUAL WORKFORCE
NEEDS- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND ARE WITH ME- TO
TESTIFY- IS- TERROR- TARA. GUMBO
EASTMAN AND DR MAXWELL DAVIS-
AND I THINK GO DOCTOR DAVIS IS
HEREBY PROBLEM OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER WINNER WILL NOW MOVE
TOWARD LEAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I WILL BEGIN WITH A- W.
SPENT STEINBERG INSTITUTE YOU
HAVE. MINUTES THEN BUILD ON THE
NEXT WITNESS WELCOME THANK YOU.
GOOD MR CHAIR TARGET BY EASEMENT
ON BEHALF OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE'RE AN INDEPENDENT
NON PROFIT PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE DEDICATED TO ADVANCING
FOUND PUBLIC POLICY AND
INSPIRING LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE THE BRAIN HEALTH. AT THE
VERY PROUD SPONSORS OF SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR. TODAY DEATHS FROM
OPIOIDS AND MATH ARE
SKYROCKETING FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
LIVE WIT A SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS AND RATES OF DEPRESSION
AMONG OUR YOUTH. HAVE INCREASED
BY 50% OVER THE LAST DECADE
CONTRIBUTING TO A DOUBLING OF E.
R. VISITS BY SUICIDAL CHILDREN
AND TEENS WE ARE FACING A
DEVASTATING. DEADLY MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
CRISIS. BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
VIRTUALLY POWERLESS TO SOLVE IT
AS WE FACE A SECOND CRISIS IN
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE. AS SENATOR WIENER
MENTIONED OVER HALF OF COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BOTH A HIGH
NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND FACE A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. IF WE'RE TO
HAVE ANY HOPE OF SUSTAINABLY
ADDRESSING THE- BRIDGE TO GET
CALIFORNIA A LIFESAVING CARE
THAT THEY NEED. WE HAVE TO
CREATE CLEAR ACADEMIC PIPELINES
THAT SUPPORTS STUDENTS FOR THE
CHALLENGING JOB AHEAD AND ENSURE
THEY ENTER THE WORK FORCE
WITHOUT THE BURDEN OF EXCESSIVE
STUDENT LOANS. THIS BILL TAKES A
FIRST STEP TO ENSURE OUR
STUDENTS HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO ENTER THE WORK FORCE
INSPIRED AND PREPARED. BY
CREATING PAID TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES ACCELERATED
ACADEMIC PROGRAMS AND MORE
PRACTICAL CLIENT CENTERED
COURSEWORK THANK YOU SO UCH OF
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AIBO AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANKS VERY MUCH I
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS WHO BELIEVE IS ON THE
CALL IN LINE SO MODERATOR
PLEASE- LINE UP- NEXT- DR HE
MAXED WILL DAVIS- FOR. HIS AT UC
BERKELEY AFTER TESTIMONY YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. HELLO MY NAME
IS. IMPACTFUL DAVIS AND I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIAL WORK EDUCATION CENTER.
WHICH IS THE NATION'S LARGEST
SOCIAL WORK WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND HOW
DIFFICULT SOCIAL WELFARE YOU
DIRECTLY- I'M PROVIDING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. ARE BECAUSE I CONDUCTED A
RETROSPECTIVE STUDY OF OUR-
FORMER STATE WIDE AND I FELT
GRADING PROGRAM FOCUSED ON
PREPARING- AND THE FOR THE
FUTURE. FOR WORK IN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. I WHICH WAS PREVIOUSLY
FUNDED BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
AND TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. BY
THE WORKFORCE EDUCATION TRAINING
COMPONENT OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT- THAT PROGRAM TRADE
THE TOTAL OF TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE MSW
GRADUATE AT. TWENTY FEET AND
ASSEMBLY PROGRAM. AND ARE STATUS
ACTIVE OF PRO IMPACT AND FOLLOW
UP WITH GRADUAL- INDICATE THAT
IT WAS. QUITE ACCEPT IN
ACHIEVING ITS PROGRAM GOAL-
INCLUDING. GRADUATING ALMOST 62%
OF GRADUATES ARE OF COLOR- 50%
OF GRADUATES WHO WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH- OVER 26%
TRAINEES WHO IDENTIFIED AS
CONSUMERS OF PUBLIC BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES THEMSELVES. AND
ALMOST NINE PER SENATE-ROOM
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO WORK CONSUMERS AND
THE PUBLIC THAT THE- WHILE THE
CREW. FOR THE PROGRAM. ANOTHER
BIG WITH MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WAS NO DIEGO THIS. OF PROGRAM
BENEFITS- ARE RESEARCH INDICATES
THAT 99% OF TRADING SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED ALL ASPECTS OF
TRAINING- OVER ALMOST 94% OF
THEM COMPLETED THE REQUIRED
SERVICE OBLIGATION IN THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WITH THEM
AFTER GRADUATING- AND THAT.
THESE GRADUATES WITH IN FIFTY
OUR STATE FIFTY NINE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
PROVIDE SERVICE AFTER GRADUATION
IN FIFTY FOUR OF THE- PUBLIC
THAT PLEASE WRAP UP YOUR TWO
ALMOST NINETY TWO PERCENT. THESE
CONTINUED WORKING THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM AFTER COMPLETING SERVICE
OBLIGATION FOR AN AVERAGE OF
FOUR POINT ONE OF YEARS AT THE
POINT THAT WE REACH THEM. AND AT
THE POINT SURVEYS PLEASE. 56% OF
THEM WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
THAT. THANK YOU. HI THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
APOLOGIZE YOU YOU ARE OVER TIME
SO- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA NOW MOVES TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT- HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. THE
WITNESSES WHICH THAT'S FINE
SUPPORT FROM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
SEEN APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
. THANK YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. CANADA'S ONE
AND THEN THERE APPEARED SUPPORT
- ABOUT TRYING TO THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKYOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BECOMING.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU ONE ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS AFK ARE FULL WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. WHY NOT
TWO FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. ROB LANE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
AGENCY THANKS FOR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE OF THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING REBECCA
GONZALES WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINETY SIX FOUR THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LIKE ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS A TREND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM
OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT YEAH
THANK YOU SIX WITNESS. TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GRACE WHY I'M A MASTERS IN
SOCIAL WORK STUDENT IN THE ECHO
STATE UNIVERSITY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTY. THANK YOU YOUR
NEXT WITNESS. LIKE TO TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS TERRY CHÁVEZ
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS WORKING
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JEFF
WEINER JEWISH FAMILY AND
CHILDREN'S SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FOR THIS IMPORTANT YOU AT THIS
TIME THANKS VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND OF MODERATOR
BELIEVE WE HAVE. VIRGINIA MAY-
FROM THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WILL BE TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION
- VILLAGE VIA TELECONFERENCE
LINE SO YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
PLEASE BRING ON VIRGINIA MAY. HI
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SENATOR PAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
JENNY MADE BY PRESIDENT OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. REPRESENTING
THE ACADEMIC SENATE BUT THE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN AND TEN
DISTRICTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND
AREAS OF CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION. THANK YOU FOR THIS
TIME TO MEET WITH YOU AND THANK
YOU. INTEREST IN SUPPORT AND
ENSURING THAT THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS PROVIDE
CURRENT AND NEEDED CURRICULAR
OFFERINGS. IN ORDER TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS. AND THE
COMMUNITY PLAN FOR. THIS IS THE
PRIMARY PHONE. OF ACADEMICS. TO
DEVELOP AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING COLLEGE CURRICULAR
PROGRAMS. THE AIR OPC UP THE
ACADEMIC SENATE THROUGH THE
RESOLUTION PROCESS HAVE BEEN
DIRECTED TO TAKE A POSITION OF
OPPOSE ON PROPOSED LEGISLATION
THAT ESTABLISHES CURRICULUM FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE A
CIRCLE THE CURRICULUM AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
. FIVE THE ANSWER THEME OPPOSE
SB NINE FOUR IN ITS CURRENT FORM
TO DATE THERE HAVE BEEN NO
DIALOGUE WITH THE A TRIPLE THREE
MORE WITH THE ACADEMIC SENATE
BUT THE CSU AND UC SYSTEM
REGARDING THE CURRICULAR
MANDATES THAT WOULD ARISE FROM
THE BILL. BUT THERE'S STILL
TIME. CURRENTLY ON THE C. IDE
CORP IDENTIFICATION. NUMBER
SYSTEM LET. THERE ARE A FEW
THINGS. SUCH AS MODEL CURRICULUM
IN ADDICTION STUDIES AND
TRANSFER MODEL CURRICULUM IN
PUBLIC HEALTH SCIENCE AND SOCIAL
WORK AND HUMAN SERVICES. THE AIR
STRIP OF THE WELCOME PROFESSION
WITH THE SENATOR AND HIS STAFF
REGARDING SOLUTION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN ADEQUATE
LICENSE CERTIFIED OR REGISTERED
CLINICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES IN OUR COMMUNITY I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SIXTY
FOUR- SO HERE RUN TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED WELCOME THANK THANK YOU-
MARY MORE OIL WITH THE CSU WERE
MORE OF A TWEENER WE DON'T HAVE
A OPPOSITION PSITION YET AND WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING TO THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE. HI THIS IS A
VERY BROAD BILL AND WE VALUE ITS
GOALS TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF M.
S. W. HOWEVER WE HAVE TO VERY
SPECIFIC ISSUE WITH THE FIRST
PART OF THE BELL AT THE ANALYSIS
NOTE ADDING THE MANDATE IS.
WORTH FOR ALL AND IT'S W.
REGARDING OTHER SPECIALIZED. THE
GREAT. OKAY YOU THINK TREASON
INTO HER. ADDING AND AN
ADDITIONAL COURSE WILL ALSO
REQUIRE A REVIEW PROCESS FOR
ACCREDITATION AS PROGRAMS ARE
CHANGE. I CAN'T BE- PER
PROVISIONS ON THE BILL ON USING
CURRENT- ON ON USING CREDIT FOR
PRIOR LEARNING ARE ACTUALLY IN
CONFLICT WITH CURRENT
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS WHICH
WITH THE BEST THE COLLEGES NOT
USE COURSE CREDIT FOR WORK
EXPERIENCE ALTERNATIVELY THEY
HAVE STUDENTS COMPLETE MONITOR
CLINICAL PLATE PLACEMENT. SO IN
IN SOME WEIRD ARE CONCERNED THAT
THESE CHANGES WILL ACTUALLY SLOW
DOWN ANY EFFORTS TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF M. S. W. GRADS QUITE
QUICKLY- BUT WE DO HOPE TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
ON THE ON THE STAGE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU CENTER
PAN FOR YOUR HELP WHILE I WAS IN
LECTIONS COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
IT. ALL RIGHT SO WE HAD TO THE
TWEEN OR DO WE HAVE. BEAUTIFUL
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER GOOD
MORNING. ARE IS THERE ANYONE IN.
THIS ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHO
WISHES TO OPPOSE SB NINE SIXTY
FOUR. SEEING NONE MADAM- KANNST
SORRY. RUNNING AROUND OF
MATAMATA READER IF YOU'LL PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE.
THANK YOU IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
THE ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR IN
OPPOSITION. WE WILL GO TO LINE A
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES NICOLE YOUNG OF PLASTER
COUNTY AND MONSTER LIBERTY AT
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT TO THE LINE TO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOREARM IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU CAN'T GET
THROUGH TE SCIENCE OF FACE
MASKS WHICH IS BASICALLY YOUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ABOUT THE LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM A I'M OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU MY NAME'S MICHAEL
BERMAN. THANK YOU MICHAEL. THANK
YOU. AND ONE MOMENT MA'AM CARE
WE JUST HAVE A FEW MORE THAT
NEEDS THE LINE NUMBERS. AGAIN WE
ARE ON OPPOSITION SB NINE SIXTY
FOUR. WE WILL GO LINE UP TO
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
ARTICLE IN OPIUM ACT AS A
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB NINE
SIX FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEXICO LINES TO FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DAISY AND I OPPOSE THE
FELT. THANK YOU MEXICO CAROLINA
ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI YES- MY NAME IS SANDY
HOAGLAND AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
. THANK YOU FOR GOING TO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS JENNIFER AND I OPPOSE SB.
NINE FOUR. THANK YOU FOR GOAL
LINE OF TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI AGAIN VOEPEL
REGISTERED VOTER AND I OPPOSE
THEMSELVES TO BROADLY WRITTEN.
THANK YOU NEXT TO THE LINE OF
TWO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. MY NAME IS SANDRA BROWN AND I
OPPOSE STC NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
ALL RIGHT WE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AS BIG AS WE
ARE HERE- SENATOR VOTED YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS I DO OKAY I KNOW I'M-
SO. WE HAVE A BIGGER PROBLEM
ISSUE- FOR ACROSS THE STATE AND
THERE'S A GREAT NEED FOR BEAVER
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. AND I'VE
IN SUPPORT OF EVERYTHING IS A
MATTER OF FACT I WAS IN ABSOLUTE
SUPPORT WHEN I READ THIS I
THOUGHT THIS IS GREAT YOU YOU
KNOW STREAMLINED THE PROCESS
AND- ALLOCATE SOME FUNDING FOR
IT AB IT JUST IT JUST ON A GREAT
BUT I AM I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR-
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP AS TO. THE
IMPLICATIONS THAT THIS BILL WILL
HAVE ON IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM
AND THE IMPACT IT WILL HAVE IN
OUR SCHOOLS. IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION. YEAH SO FIRST OF ALL
WE ARE- WE'RE ALREADY IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE CSU.
FACULTY AND I APPRECIATE THE-
WITH US TODAY- WITH- I THINK
DESCRIBED HERSELF AS A TWEENER-
I PRESUME A KNOWLEDGE OR NOT
WORKING AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM- WE UNDERSTAND
ANYTIME YOU'RE- CHANGING
CURRICULUM IT'S COMPLICATED. YOU
HAVE TO BE CLOBBERED AND WE ARE.
ON I'LL BE HONEST WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACADEMIC
SENATE THIS IS LITERALLY OUT OF
MY FIELD THE FIRST TIME. WE'VE
HEARD ANYTHING FROM THEM THEY
DON'T SUBMIT A LETTER TO NEVER
REACH OUT EXPRESSING CONCERNS.
ON IN CONTRAST TO THE CSU
FACULTY WHO DID REACH ON WE'VE
BEEN MEETING WITH THEM IN ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE. SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. FACULTY WE WANTED TO
WORK AND WE WELCOME. FEEDBACK
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT WE ARE
HAVING THIS PROFOUND SHORTAGE
OUT OVER THE NEXT DECADE. IS
GOING GOT MORE. FIRST AND WE%
HAVE TO RAMP UP- THESE DEGREE
PROGRAMS AND SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF ACTUALLY HAVING
THE PROGRAMS. HAVING THE
ACCELERATION AND THEN PROVIDING
THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES. SO WE
GOT MORE PEOPLE FRIENDS SO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM
OF COURSE. OKAY WONDERFUL WELL
ON. WITH THAT COMMITMENT OF
CONTINUING COLLABORATION IN
TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK FOR ME
WHICH IS R. C. SEASON NINE
VENTRALLY IF THEY COME ON BOARD
THE UC'S- I WILL MOVE FORWARD
IN- THE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO. AB. DE
CONTINUE COLLABORATION. THE YOU
SENATOR JOE CENTER WIENER ARTS
USED AN APPENDAGE OF ANY
QUESTIONS PLEASE AHEAD AFTER
JUST AGAIN THANK YOU SO WIENER
FOR BRING THIS- BILL. AND HAD A
CHANCE HEAR AND HEALTH COMMITTEE
KNOW HERE IN EDUCATE WITH FOR
FROM SOME EDUCATE FOLKS. AND-
BUT THE SO I KNOW YOU'LL BE
REACHING OUT TO THEM- I GUESS I
WOULD SAY IS SOMEONE WHO'S A-
FORMER FACULTY MEMBERI'M A
STRONG PROPONENT OF ACADEMIC
FREEDOM- AND- SO I THINK
CERTAINLY THE FACULTY HAVE US-
YEAH PRIMIT ROLLED. SENATE
CURRICULA BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO DO
POLICY HERE. AND I THINK THE
POLICY GOALS CERTAINLY ONE
THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO SET SAY LOOK WE-
DO TO TRY TO SELL. I KNOW YOU
GUYS STRIKE THAT BALANCE AND SO
AS ONLY BE SUPPORTING THE BILL%
THANKS SO MUCH I MEAN FOR. THE
SENATE PANTS AND A WIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- I'D APPRECIATE
FEEDBACK AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
OPERANT AIBO WHENEVER
REQUIREMENTS AND- THANK YOU
ACTUALLY DID HAVE A WE HAVE A
QUORUM JOY AND EMOTIONAL
MOVEMENT-O'DONNELL. EXCELLENT
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR. PAN MEN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR ITEM
NUMBER. SB NINE SIX FOUR MOTION
IS DUE PASS BUT FOR BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA HI LEYVA
OHIO CHOI BOGUE. RITUAL BOGART
CORTESE. DALLY GLAZER. MCGUIRE
PAN HI PAM I. THANK YOU MA'AM
CONSULTANT CENTER AYE WIENER YOU
HAVE OUR NEXT BILLS WELL SB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- TODAY I'M PRESENTING SPLM
FORTY FOR THE SAFE AND EFFICIENT
WATER ACT I CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADING EXAMPLE FOR THE NATION%
IN THE WORLD ON SO MANY
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES. HOWEVER
OUR DRINKING WATER REGULATIONS
DO NOT ALWAYS- PASS MUSTER I
KNOW WHERE IS THIS MORE EVIDENT
THAN IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS- DATA
COLLECTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY. SHOW THAT SHOWED
THAT 53% OF REPORTING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOUND LEAD IN AT LEAST
ONE OF THEIR DRINKING WATER
FOUNTAINS ON CAMPUS OF TRAINING
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED DRINKING
WATER FOUNTAINS TESTED POSITIVE.
FOR LEAD- THIRTEEN HUNDRED-
SCHOOLS UNFORTUNATELY THE ISSUE
DOESN'T STOP IT LET THE SAME
WATER SYSTEMS MAY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED EXPOSING STUDENTS TO
LEGIONELLA RATE I'D AND A HOST
OF OTHER POTENTIALLY HARMFUL
CONTAMINANTS- THE- HOWEVER THE
TESTING THAT BROUGHT THIS DATA
TO LIGHT DID NOT REQUIRE
TESTING. FOR THESE OTHER NON
LEAD- CONTAMINANT ONLY LEAD
TESTING WAS REQUIRED WITHOUT A
TESTING REGIME THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE. TO OPERATE IN
DARKNESS- ASSUMING THAT STATE
SCHOOLS AND STATE AGENCIES ARE
FILLING CALIFORNIA'S- RIGHT TO
CLEAN AND SAFE WATER. SB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR WILL REMEDY THIS
ISSUE BY REQUIRING ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND- OWN BUILDINGS TO
COMPLETE A WATER QUALITY
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR FACILITIES.
INCLUDING TEST FOR LEAD RATE ON
THESE YOU KNOW- AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS IF THEY FIND A
CONTAMINATED CONTAMINANT THE
AGENCY OR SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL
BE REQUIRED TO REPLACE THE
PICTURE. AT THE EARLIEST
PRACTICAL TIME SUBJECT TO
FUNDING- IF MONEY IS NOT
AVAILABLE AND REPLACEMENT IS NOT
AVAILABLE THE OPERATING AGENCY
WILL BE EXPECTED TO PREPARE
WATER QUALITY MANAGEMENT PLAN.
THAT INCLUDES INTERIM
REMEDIATION MEASURES AS WELL AS. REGULAR TESTING. I MADE REASON
FROM THE NATION'S SCHOOL AND
STATE AGENCY IS NEEDS OF THESE
BUILDINGS OLD PLUMBING SO. ARE
OFTEN MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
POTENTIAL POLLUTION ARE MORE
LIKELY TO CONTAIN LEAD AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS. ADDITIONALLY THESE
OLD SYSTEMS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BE INEFFICIENT EITHER BY LEAKING
AND WASTING POTENTIALLY
THOUSANDS OF GALLONS OF WATER.
OR BY SIMPLY UTILIZING EXCESSIVE
WATER FOR THEIR FUNCTIONS
COMPARED TO MODERN FIXTURES AND
APPLIANCES- SO- AS A RESULT SB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR WILL
ADDITIONALLY REQUIRE SCHOOLS AND
STATE AGENCIES. TO TEST THEIR
WATER EFFICIENCY- AND SUBJECT TO
FUNDING I REPLACE FIXTURES-
APPLIANCES THAT DON'T MEET STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY STANDARDS AND
FINALLY THE BILL REQUIRE SCHOOLS
AND STATE AGENCIES. TO DETERMINE
THE FEASIBILITY OF INSTALLING
ONSITE GREYWATER SYSTEMS I GOT
NOT REQUIRE IT BUT REQUIRE AT
LEAST A FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS- WE
ARE WORKING ON AMENDMENTS. WITH
THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING- CASH AND WE HOPE
TO ADDRESS- SOME OF THE CONCERNS
LAID OUT IN THEIR LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE- AND I'M COMMITTED TO
THAT DIALOGUE OVER THE COMING
WEEKS WE KNOW THERE COST ISSUES
HERE- WE TRY TO BE FLEXIBLE IN
THE BILL AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK. OUT WITH THEM- IT BY I
THINK BOTTOM LINE AND BIG
PICTURE- IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO
HAVE A PUBLIC. WHETHER IS
POTENTIAL CAP CONTAMINATION THE
SYSTEMS THAT'S BAD FOR EVERYONE
BUT PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN
WHO ARE DEVELOPING WHERE WE KNOW
THESE CONTAMINANTS CAN BE EVEN
MORE HARMFUL- THEN FOR THE
POPULATION AT LARGE- WE NEED TO
KNOW- AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. ON WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY- IT'S GOT WATCH ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL OUR SPONSOR. AND THOMAS
AND SLOW ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
PLUMBING AND MECHANICAL
OFFICIALS. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER. A MISTER WHICH PLEASE
RECEIVE YOUR READY OF TWO
MINUTES. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M SCOTT WHICH I'M ACTUALLY
HERE ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL AND THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF OUR PLUMBING AND
MECHANICAL OFFICIALS. IAPMO IS.
THE ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
ALL THE PLUMBING INSPECTORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
ALSO THE ENTITY THAT PUBLISHES
THE UNIFORM PLUMBING CODE SO
IT'S THE BODY THAT SETS. UP OUR
WATER PLUMBING STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE PURPOSE FOR
BEHIND ELEVEN FORTY FOUR IS THE
FACT THAT WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
AN EXTREMELY SEVERE LEAD. ISSUE
IN OUR PIPES IN PUBLIC BUILDINGS
AND SPECIFICALLY IN SCHOOLS. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE SEEN AN ALARMING
INCREASE IN THE- NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT BACTERIUM RELATED
DISEASES THAT ARE RELATED TO
PLUMBING SYSTEMS. MOST
SPECIFICALLY AS MENTIONED BY THE
AUTHOR LEGIONELLA DISEASE. BUT
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS HIGHLY
UNDER REPORTED BUT NATIONALLY WE
HAVE IN THE LAST REPORTABLE YEAR
OVER TEN THOUSAND CASES OF
LEGIONELLA. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO AREN'T AWARE ONE OUT OF
EVERY TEN PEOPLE WHO GET
LEGIONELLA. PERISH FROM IT. IS
EXTREMELY SERIOUS DISEASES SAID
OUTBREAK TWO WEEKS AGO IN A IN A
HOTEL IN HAWAII. WE THINK THIS
IS A VERY REASONABLE BILL I JUST
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE OPPOSITION
WE CERTAINLY SHARE THE SENATOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. WE WILL NEVER WAY
DRAFTING THIS BILL TO NOT
REQUIRE REMEDIATION IF THERE
WASN'T FUNDING AVAILABLE TO OUR
SENSITIVE THAT ISSUE. BUT TO
REQUIRE THAT AT A MINIMUM.
TEACHERS AND PARENTS BE NOTIFIED
IF THERE'S A SERIOUS WATER ISSUE
WITH A SCHOOL. AND THEY PUT A
PLAN TOGETHER ON HOW TO MEDIATE
. HOW TO MITIGATE I SHOULD SAY.
ET- YOU KNOW AND LEAD CONTENT OR
OTHER DANGEROUS BACTERIA. CASH
IS WHAT OF OPPOSITION BASICALLY
STATES THAT THEY'RE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BECAUSE THERE'S NO
FUNDING WELL WE ADDRESS THE
FUNDING ISSUE ON THE REPLACEMENT
BUT TO ACCEPT YOUR ARGUMENTS ON
MERELY PUTTING TOGETHER A
MANAGEMENT PLAN IS BASICALLY A
DON'T ASK DON'T TELL POLICY. WE
DON'T WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY DANGEROUS BACTERIUM IN THE
PIPES WE DON'T WANT TO KNOW IF
THERE'S LEAD AND WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO TELL OUR PARENTS
AND TEACHERS- BECAUSE THERE'S NO
FUNDING. TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THIS IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE. AND
WE WOULD URGEAN AYE VOTE BE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR IS MR
IN SLOW HERE. I SPOKE FOR USED
OKAY IF YOU DID GO A LITTLE OVER
SO I WAS THINKING THAT WAS THE
CASE VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER
WET. OKAY NEXT WE'LL TAKE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO ONE ELSE MADAM
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE. ON THE PHONE LINES
WAS IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE A
PART OF SB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOU HAVE A SEMI OF. YES-
VERY HEAVY ON THE- AND- OFFENDER
ARE THAT- BUT DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ARE WANTING TO- THE TICKET FROM
UNKNOWN UNKNOWN PATHOGENS OKAY
SIR I'M SORRY WE'RE JUST TAKING
WHAT IS YOUR NAME IN SUPPORT
PLEASE. OKAY MY NAME IS MICHAEL
SIMMONS AT THE PORTAGE TERRIFIC
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWO
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS THERESA PELLEGRINO
AND I AM HE HIT MEDLEY AGAINST
THIS BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE QUEUE UP. THANK YOU
ARE GO TO LINE TWO FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWO FORTY
FIVE YOU MAY BEGIN. I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
FOR THIS IMPORTANT TO YOU AT
THIS TIME GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE HERE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
SEEING NO ONE META MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO OPPOSE S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF SP
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN THERE ARE FEW AND
OPPOSITION UP AT. ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR. AND ONE MOMENT MANAGER WE
DO HAVE ONE QUEUED UP THANK YOU.
AGAIN WE ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES I WAS TOLD I WAS ONE
THIRTY BUT I'LL GO AHEAD AND
SPEAK MY LINES OPEN. YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS ROBERT
BOCOCK AND WATER TREATMENT
PROFESSIONAL FROM THE CHINO
BASIN ARE YOUR HOME DISTRICT YES
I AM STANDING IN OPPOSITION AND
TELL- AMENDMENTS CAN BE BE
NEGOTIATED WITH THE SPONSOR AND
THE SENATOR'S OFFICE GREAT THANK
YOU I REPRESENTS YOUR BRAND
IMAGE. IN HERE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN KILL OKAY
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS- SO I
ANOTHER PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU SENATOR LEYVA M. I
APPRECIATE THE- THE INTENT OF
THE BILL BUT I AM CONCERNED- ON
THE LIABILITY THAT HAPPENS- AND
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU COULD EXPAND
ON THIS BUT- I KNOW THAT IN REAL
ESTATE- WE DO CONTRACTS AND WE
DO- AT ANY INVESTIGATION OR
STUDY ON. A HOME- WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DISCLOSING THAT
TO THE POTENTIAL BUYER. AND THEN
IT'S A GO SHE DIDN'T ON YOU KNOW
WHO PAYS FOR THE WORK AND SO
FORTH BUT IT IT IT BECOMES OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP TAKING
CARE OF. WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
FACILITIES- ANYTHING THAT STATE-
ALLOCATED ONE I WAS KIND OF
CURIOUS YOUR PREVIOUS BILL NOTE
THAT YOU JUST PRESENTED YOU DID
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO.
ALLOCATE SOME FUNDING OR AT
LEAST REQUEST FUNDING TO HAVE
THE WORK DONE. SITTING I BUDGET
SUB ONE I. WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN
NOT- ALLOCATING FUNDING FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND SOME OF
OUR SCHOOLS ARE IN SEVERE
DETERIORATION FOR- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND NOT HAVING THE
FUNDING I MEAN THE WORKLOAD HAS
BEEN EXPONENTIAL SO I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS AS TO ONE AB WHY DIDN'T
YOU ALLIGATOR OR SORT OF CREATE
A FUNDING SOURCE OR A- JUST AS A
MEANS BY WHICH THIS CAN BE DONE
. THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
BESIDES THE FUNDING DOING
INVESTIGATION DURING THE STUDIES
KNOWING THAT IT'S THAT THAT
THERE IS A PROBLEM AN ISSUE
PUTTING THE NOTICES ON THERE.
I'M I'M LOOKING AT IT FROM AN
ATTORNEY'S PERSPECTIVE THE
LIABILITY THAT COMES ACROSS THE
STATE AND IS THIS OPEN A
LITIGATION NIGHTMARE FOR MANY OF
THESE- FOR THE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. THAT IT NOW ARE
DISCLOSING THERE'S A PROBLEM
HERE BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
ALLOCATED FUNDING FROM THE STATE
SO THE LEAGUE LITIGATION I DON'T
WANT THIS AND I WOULD HATE FOR
THE STATE TO SPEND MONEY ON
LITIGATION. VERSUS ALLOCATING
THE MONEY UP FRONT TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THIS ISSUE. SO IN
TERMS OF LITIGATION IF I WERE
INTENDANT I WOULD BE MUCH MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT LITIGATION IF A
CHILD DRINKS CONTAMINATED WATER
AND GETS SICK OR DIES. RIGHT AT
RIVER MULTIPLE CHILDREN GOD
FORBID THAT THAT TO ME IS A
LITIGATION NIGHTMARE IT IS MUCH
BETTER FRANKLY FOR EVERYONE FOR
HELP WILL HELP THE COMMUNITY.
AND FOR AVOIDING LITIGATION TAX
YOU KNOW AND SO IF THERE IS
CONTAMINATION SAY AND A DRINKING
WATER SYSTEM MAYBE THEY SHUT IT
OFF UNTIL THEY CAN FIGURE IT OUT
AND BRING IN- AN EXTERNAL SOURCE
OF WATER- I DON'T. I CAN'T
ENVISION ANY ARGUMENT TO SAY
THAT SCHOOLS SHOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO KNOW IF THEIR WATER
SYSTEMS ARE CONTAMINATED WITH
LEAD WITH RADEON WITH WHICH AN
ALOT- AND. AND THEN THEY CAN
TAKE ACTION. I AGREE WITH YOU
THOUSAND. I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A
MASSIVE INVESTMENT IN OUR AGING.
SCHOOL AFTER SCHOOL FACILITIES
FOR- PLUMBING SYSTEM FOR BETTER
VENTILATION FOR FUNCTIONING.
TOILETS AND ALL THE OTHER
PROBLEMS AND I WITHOUT GETTING
SIDETRACKED I WOULD SAY THIS IS
WHY. I HAVE MAJOR ISSUES WITH.
TAKING SO MUCH OF OUR SURPLUS
AND READY AND SENDING CHECKS TO
PEOPLE. AS OPPOSED TO USING THIS
SURPLUS TO FOR EXAMPLE FIX OUR
SCHOOLS AND A LOT OF POLITICAL
PRESSURE WERE REGARDING. YOU
KNOW. SOME MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEMAND THAT WE
SEND MORE MORE MONEY BACK TO
TAXPAYERS WHO ARE NOT LOW
INCOME. AS OPPOSED TO USING THAT
TO FIX OUR TOILETS AND WATER
SYSTEMS INPUT FILTER VENTILATION
SYSTEMS AS WELL I JUST HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THAT. THAT'S A
SEPARATE ISSUE SO I AM ALL FOR
MASSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT IN OUR SCHOOLS- HOPE
THAT WE GET THERE. BUT TO BE
CLEAR THIS. LEGISLATION IS A
STEP TO SAY LET'S AT LEAST KNOW
IF WHAT THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM
AS AND MAKE SURE THAT IF A
SCHOOL DOES HAVE A CONTAMINATION
PROBLEM. THAT THE KIDS ARE NOT
GETTING SICK AND THAT TEACHERS
AND PARENTS AND KIDS NOW YOU CAN
MAKE ALTERNATE ARRANGEMENTS IF
THEY HAVE TO BRING IN BOTTLED
WATER. THEY CAN DO THAT- BUT NOT
KNOWING. IS UNACCEPTABLE IN MY
VIEW. AND I AM COMPLETELY WITH
YOU WHICH IS WHY I APPRECIATE
AND REALLY RESPECT THE MERITS OF
THE BILL I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
DOING THIS THERE WERE ALSO
PROTECTING FOR MY ABILITY TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN. IN IN IN
PLACE- UNTIL THEY- IT FOR TO BE
ABLE TO CARE OF THE- PROBLEM
BECAUSE I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
YOU. I THINK WE SHOULD BE
SPENDING OUR OUR RESOURCES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WE'VE HAD A
PROBLEM AND THEREFORE. YOU KNOW
I'VE HEARD I REMEMBER SEVERAL
YEARS AGO I ATTENDED A WATER
SUMMIT IN THE STATE OF.
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T HAVE SO MUCH
A WATER PROBLEM BUT MORE OF AN
INFRASTRUCTURE A PROBLEM THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF THE PROJECT
YOU PLACE AND WE HAVE A VERY
VERY OLD SYSTEM. IN PLACE THAT
NEEDS TO BE UPDATED SO I'M
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT. AND IF
THIS MOVES FORWARD- THAT. MAYBE
YOU HAVE A COMMITMENT TO.
INCLUDE A- A STIPULATION WHAT WE
ACTUALLY PROTECT THE SCHOOL
pFUNDING AVAILABLE- THAT THEY CAN
ONE AS YOU SAID BRING OTHER
WATER RESOURCES INTO PLACE THAT
THEY HAVE OTHER OPTIONS BESIDES.
AND HAVE THE PROTECTION THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
LITIGATED WHAT WHAT I. A I THINK
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO BE
LITIGATED IF THEY ACTUALLY.
POISONED STUDENTS OVER THE WATER
POISONS TO INSPECT BUT I WILL
COMMIT IS THAT GOING FORWARD NOT
INCOME COMING YEARS. WE NEED TO
GET MORE FUNDING TO OUR SCHOOLS
TO ACTUALLY UPDATE THEIR
PLUMBING SYSTEM. THERE'S
POPULOUS. SUPPORT FOR THAT- AND
SO THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M WHO I AM
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO. BE UP
THERE WELL I'M CONFIDENT THERE
WILL BE WORK TO DO THAT. SO IN
OTHER WORDS. IF THIS BILL WERE
SUPPOSED PASSES THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE AND WE IMPLEMENTED IN
THE STUDIES DO YOU GO THROUGH-
ASIDE FROM THE FACT THAT THEY
WOULD BE LIABLE TO LOCATION OR
SOMEONE IS GET SICK WHICH AS A
MOM I'M I'M ALL ABOUT PROTECTING
YOUR KIDS. THERE'S NO POSSIBLE
WAY THAT YOU COULD PROTECT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM LITIGATION
UNTIL THEY HAVE THE FUNDING
PROVIDED I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
BILL INCREASES THEIR- ASIAN
EXPOSURE. THIS BILL IF ANYTHING
REDUCES- BECAUSE THEY WILL KNOW
OKAY WE HAVE ONE LETTER READ ON
IN OUR WATER. AND SO WE DON'T
WANT OUR KIDS TO DRINK THAT
ANYMORE WE'RE GOING TO BRING AN
EXTERNAL SOURCE OF WATER.
INSTEAD OF THE DRINKING
FOUNTAINS UNTIL WE CAN FIND A
WAY TO REMEDIATE IT. THAT
REDUCES THEIR LIABILITY I THINK
JUST. FOR THIS FOR THEM NOT TO
KNOW THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN A KID
GET SECOND LIKE- HOW DID THIS
COULD. YOU NOW- AND THEN IN
LEADING BEEN AS A LAWSUIT FILED
A TO. DISCOVERY THEY FIND OUT
THAT THERE THAT THE WATER
SYSTEMS CONTAMINATED THAT SEEMS
LIKE A BIGGER HEADACHE
LITIGATION WISE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THAN DOING THE STUDY
AND BEING ABLE TO SHUT THINGS
DOWN IF THERE'S A PROBLEM. THAT
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
UNDERPANTS THANK THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE AND I APOLOGIZE I.
THINK I STEPPED OUT DURING THE
OPPOSITION'S TESTIMONY BUT- I
JUST TO CLARIFY AND- BECAUSE I
NOTICED THAT THE- COLLISION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING- THE
CASSIA. IT WAS HIS EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION IS THERE IS THERE
SOME CONCERN THAT THE STANDARDS
THAT YOU'RE REQUIRING FOR
TESTING THE WATER IN THIS BILL
ARE DIFFERENT THAN THE STANDARD
SCHOOLS ALREADY USED TO. TEST
THEIR WATER. WHITE I THINK THAT
THE SENDS IN THE BILL ARE ARE
PRETTY- ACCEPTED STANDARD BUT-
WE DID HAVE- I DIDN'T MENTION
WHETHER WE'RE ABSOLUTELY GOING
TO WORK WITH K. K. RESPONSES OF
IT ABOUT SO WE WERE. OR STARTING
A CONVERSATION WITH THEM AND
WE'RE GONNA DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO TRY TO- TO TRY TO HAVE A
RESOLUTION OKAY ALL RIGHT I
APPRECIATE IT I MEAN. THE AND I
KNOW YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
AB C. BECAUSE WE NEED TO BE
SURE- ELEANOR FOR KIDS TO LEARN
THEY NEED TO. BE SAFE AND THAT
INCLUDES HAVING STATE WATER AND
SAFE FAIR AND SCHOOLS RIGHT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TIME IN
SCHOOLS. AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT- I ALSO YOU
KNOW SOMEONE WHO SAID ON C. L.
CATION BOARD- NOTES ON THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE IN TERMS OF
FUNNY BUT YOU'RE RIGHT I MEAN
IT'S- THEN WE NEED TO VERIFY THE
PROBLEMS AND THEN IF I WHAT IT'S
GONNA TAKE TO FIX THEM AND STEP
UP AND- TAKE CARE OF THAT. YEAH
WHAT IDEAS INSTEAD OF INSTEAD OF
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS PER CAR WE
CAN DO FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
. WHAT ABOUT HELP. ALL RIGHT
OKAY WELL- ALL RIGHT WELL THAT.
PLEASE ARTICLE GOING BACK TO.
YEAH WELL I. AND DISAGREE WITH
YOU WELL I- BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
TALKING ABOUT NOW- SO WITH THAT
. I WILL BE THE BILL A BID TO
BUILD PROTOTYPE THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN- THE CENTER WE ARE
ONE OF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I'VE DONE A
NUMBER OF BILLS MYSELF ON NOT
LEAD. PIPES IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
MAKING SURE OUR CHILDREN HAVE
SAFE DRINKING WATER IT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WERE STILL WORRYING ABOUT THESE
PROBLEMS. STONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRING IT FORWARD- WE
HAVE A MOTION BUT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE HER QUESTION I WROTE
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL FOR ALL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE. REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE OCHO BOAT HI. SOCIAL BURBANK
FOR TENNESSEE. VALLEY GLAZER.
RAZOR I'D MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN I
THANK YOU MA'AM CONSULTANT ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT AUTHORS LET SENATOR
MELINDA. ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
TEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- AND GOOD MORNING
TODAY I'M HERE TO REPRESENT ALL
PARENTS IN PRESENTING TO U. S.
B. TEN FORTY FIVE. SB TEN FORTY
FIVE ADDS LESSON PLANS AS
DEFINED TO THE TEAM TO THE LIST
OF TEACHING MATERIALS REQUIRED
TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO PARENTS UPON
REQUEST. EXISTING LAW DECLARES
THAT ENHANCING THE ABILITY OF
PARENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS IS A
COMPELLING PUBLIC INTEREST AND
MAINTAINS THAT PARENTS HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO ACCESS RECORDS
RELATED TO THEIR CHILDREN.
NUMEROUS STUDIES A RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT STUDENT OUTCOMES
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED WHEN
PARENTS ARE INVOLVED IN STUDENTS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL RECEIVE HIGHER GRADES AND
ATTEND COLLEGE IF THEIR PARENTS
ARE ACTIVE IN THEIR EDUCATION.
SB TEN FORTY AIMED AT PROVIDING
THAT TRANSPARENCY MAKING
CURRENCY MUTUAL PARTNER IN
EDUCATING THEIR CHILDREN. THE
BILL GOES NO FURTHER THAN ADDING
LESSON PLANS TO THE LIST OF
MATERIALS ALREADY REQUIRED TO BE
ACCESSIBLE TO PARENTS. IT
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY FOR
TEACHERS TO HAVE A LESSON PLAN
POSTED WITHIN THREE DAYS OF THE
START OF THE ACADEMIC YEAR AND
OF COURSE IT ALLOWS TEACHERS THE
ABILITY TO CHANGE THEIR LESSON
PLANS AS NECESSARY. NOTHING
POSTED TO THE WEBSITE IS SET IN
STONE AND CAN BE EASILY ADJUSTED
AT THE TEACHER'S DISCRETION.
FINALLY THIS MEASURE MAKES IT
EASIER FOR PARENTS TO SEE WHAT
IS BEING TAUGHT. AND WHY IS
CURRICULUM TRANSPARENCY
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY. THE
OPPONENTS WILL SAY IT IS AN
ADDED BURDEN ALREADY BURDENED
TEACHERS BUT I SAY IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL IT IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
A CHILD'S EDUCATION THAT PARENTS
BE INCLUDED. CLASSROOMS ARE
WHERE MANY THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSIONS TAKE PLACE AND
TEACHERS ARE THERE TO TEACH HER
STUDENTS HOW TO THINK BUT NOT
WHAT TO THINK. THE GOAL IS TO
SHOW BOTH SIDES OF AN ISSUE AND
HELP STUDENTS FORM THEIR OWN
OPINIONS THIS IS HOW WE CREATE
INSIGHTFUL YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE ABLE TO DISCERN BETWEEN
SENSATIONALIZED NEWS AND THE
TRUTH. BUT AS WE KNOW PARENTS
ARE BECOMING MORE AND MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CONTENT THAT
IS BEING TAUGHT IN THE CLASSROOM
AND PARENTS DO HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW WHAT EXACTLY THEIR CHILDREN
ARE HEARING IN LEARNING. IN THE
PLACE WHERE THE BULK OF THEIR
WAKING HOURS WHICH IS AT SCHOOL.
OUR CHILDREN'S EDUCATION IS
SUPPOSED TO BE A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT BETWEEN PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS AND THE STUDENTS. AND
PROVIDING A FULLY TRANSPARENT
CURRICULUM MEANS TEACHERS ARE
INOCULATED FROM THE ANGER
PARENTS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE
SURPRISED. BY THE MATERIAL
TAUGHT IN THE CLASSROOM. MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALREADY HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE FOR POSTING
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS AND MANY
SCHOOLS ALREADY REQUIRE THEIR
TEACHERS TO SUBMIT THEIR WEEKLY
LESSON PLANS. MAKING THESE
LESSON PLANS AVAILABLE TO
PARENTS ON THE INTERNET IS NOT
DIFFICULT AND IN FACT IS ALREADY
BEING DONE IN MANY OF OUR
SCHOOLS. IF YOU GO TO A SCHOOLS
DASHBOARD YOU CAN FIND
INFORMATION ON TESTING SCORES ON
DEMOGRAPHICS AND EXTRA
CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES BUT WHERE
CAN YOU FIND THE INFORMATION ON
WHAT'S ACTUALLY BEING TAUGHT IN
THE CLASSROOM. HIDING
INFORMATION ON THE CURRICULUM
ENABLES PARENTS TO REINFORCE
CLASSROOM LEARNING. IF YOU KNOW
WHAT TOPICS YOUR CHILD IS
LEARNING ABOUT ISN'T IT A LOT
EASIER TO INITIATE CONVERSATIONS
AT THE DINNER TABLE OR IN THE
RIGHT HOME FROM SCHOOL ON THESE
TOPICS. OR SUPPLEMENT TO
CLASSROOM LEARNING BY READING
BOOKS WITH YOUR CHILD THAT BUILD
ON THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TOPIC THAT THE GOVERNING CLASS.
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL WILL
CLAIM THAT THE CURRICULUM OFTEN
CHANGES AND IT NEEDS TO CHANGE
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE VARYING NEEDS
OF INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS. AND THAT
MAY BE TRUE BUT THIS BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT TEACHRS WOULD
HAVE TO START FROM SCRATCH. AND
HAVE A RIGHT TO SEE EXACTLY WHAT
THE SCHOOLS THEY FINDER TEACHING
TO THEIR STUDENTS. AND WHERE'S
PARENTS ARE CURRENTLY PARENTS
MUST VISIT THEIR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT OFFICE TO SEE THE
CURRICULUM BUT ONLY DURING
BUSINESS HOURS. THIS MEASURE
ALLOWS THE INFORMATION TO BE
PROVIDED TO BE PROVIDED
ELECTRONICALLY. WHEN SIGNING A
CHARTER SCHOOL TRANSPARENCY BILL
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM WAS QUOTED AS
SAYING. IN ESSENCE TO ME THIS
MADE COMMONSENSE IT'S A
TRANSPARENCY BILL AND WE'RE FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND SOMETIMES
PEOPLE CLAIM THEIR FOR
TRANSPARENCY FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT NOT FOR THEMSELVES. ALLOWING
A LITTLE TRANSPARENCY FOR
PARENTS TO SEE WHAT THEIR CHILD
LEARNED IS LEARNING IS A GOOD
THING IN MY OPINION. WITH ME
HERE VIA TELECONFERENCE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL FOR LARRY
SAND A FORMER TEACHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS EMPOWERMENT
NETWORK. AND DOCTOR WHO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR EQUAL RIGHTS
FOUNDATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BUT THANK YOU CENTER
MELINDA'S ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF MR
SAM WE WILL START WITH YOU AND
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. I THANK
YOU. I'D LIKE TO START BY SAYING
BALONEY. THE FDA INSISTS THAT
EVERY LAST INGREDIENT OF THE
HEAVY HEAVILY PROCESSED FOODS
LISTED ON THE PACKAGE LABEL. NO
ONE HAS AN ISSUE WITH THIS
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
WHAT WE PUT IN OUR BODIES AND
YOU MIGHT THINK THE SAME
MENTALITY WOULD BE IN PLACE WHAT
GOES INTO OUR MINDS ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF CHILDREN BUT
UNFORTUNATE HAS BECOME A VERY
CONTENTIOUS ISSUE. WITH THE
REVELATION THAT TOO MANY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BEEN TEACHING THINGS
THAT A CONTROVERSIAL TO SAY THE
LEAST THERE IS NO PUSHBACK FROM
PARENTS IN FACT LAWMAKERS
NINETEEN STATES HAVE INTRODUCED
BILLS THAT REQUIRE. CURRICULA
TRANSPARENCY LET'S MAKE
CALIFORNIA NUMBER TWENTY. SO WHO
COULD POSSIBLY BE AGAINST THIS.
A TEACHER UNION OFFICIALLY-
UNION OFFICIAL EXCUSE ME
RECENTLY MOCKED PARENTS CALLS
FOR TRANSPARENCY SUGGESTING THAT
THEY BOUGHT OUT OF SCHOOL
AFFAIRS. A MAGAZINE WRITER
RECENTLY REFERRED TO PARENTS AS
HOUSEHOLD TYRANTS INSIST THAT
THE CALL FOR TRANSPARENT
TRANSPARENCY IS A WACKO
CHRISTIAN PLOT. THE BILL
MISSOURI WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO POST ALL TEACHER TRAINING
MATERIALS ONLINE BUT THE BILL
DREW CRITICISM FROM THE STATE
REPRESENTATIVE WHO CALLED
PROPOSAL AN ATTEMPT TO UNDERMINE
PUBLIC EDUCATION. AND THE LAST
ONE A SPOKESPERSON FOR PEN
AMERICA A GROUP WHOSE MISSION IS
TO QUOTE PROTECT FREE EXPRESSION
SAYS THAT SCHOOL TRANSPARENCY IS
ESSENTIALLY A BIG BROTHER TYPE
REGIME THAT SOUNDS GOOD ON
PAPER. BUT IT'S VERY EASY TO SEE
HOW CAN BE ABUSED TO INTIMIDATE
AND PUNISH INSTRUCTORS. BIG
BROTHER HOUSEHOLD TYRANTS
UNDERMINE PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION
HARDLY PARENTS WHO SENATE-ROOM
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT ARE
TRYING TO UNDERMINE THEM IN
REALITY JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THEIR KIDS ARE LEARNING OR NOT
LEARNING. LET ME CLOSE BY SAYING
I AM HARDLY ANTI TEACHER IN FACT
THAT TAUGHT THE TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS IN NEW YORK IN CALIFORNIA
AND I KNOW THAT MOST TEACHERS
ARE HARD WORKING AND DO THE
RIGHT THING. BUT OF COURSE THERE
ARE EXCEPTIONS AND AS A
SAFEGUARD FOR PARENTS WE
DEFINITELY NEED S. B. TEN FORTY
FIVE IS NOT INTRUSIVE. YEAH WELL
LET PARENTS KNOW JUST WHAT THEIR
PRECIOUS CHILDREN ARE LEARNING
IN SCHOOL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ARE WILL GO TO YOUR
NEXT WITNESS DR WU IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
YES NEXT YEAR A GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THIS IS WILLIAM ONE
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA. QUITE
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR
OF F. F. B. CAN FORTY FIVE. THE
BILL WOULD IN POWER PARENTS AND
IMPROVE. BY REQUIRING. THE WHAT
THE SHOWS AND EXECUTE. THEM
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION. BLOCK
ACCESS. A RECENT SURVEY BY THEM
ACCORDINGLY INSTITUTE FOR
DEMOCRACY AT PENN STATE
UNIVERSITY. SHOWS THAT 41% OF
AMERICANS THAT PARENTS SHOULD
HAVE INCREASED OVERSIGHT AND
INFLUENCE ON THE TEACHING OF
SLAVERY AND LYFT. I THINK
SCHOOL. FOLLOWED BY 33% THE
TEACHER. IF YOU WANT THAT
PARENTS SHOULD HAVE INFLUENCE ON
SEX. MARK PERCENT SAID TEACHERS
SHOULD. GIVEN EVIDENCE OF
SCHOOLS INTENTIONALLY TO.
CONTENTIOUS CONTENT CONTACT THIS
MESSAGE. FOR ACCOUNTABILITY. THE
HOBBIT CATCH. BY CHOKING BALLOT
BACK TOWARDS HIM IN A KEY THING
. AND HOW MUCH EDUCATION. THIS
IS IN LINE WITH CONVERGING
PUBLIC CONTINUE AS CREATE. BOB
EDUCATION CODE BE REQUIRED TO
SPEAK. CONSENT BEFORE DOCTOR IN
NEW CLASS ALL YOU NEED. NEARBY
THE COMPANY'S SCHOOL OFFICIALS
AND EDUCATION BUREAUCRACY THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO INCREASE BEING
AND COLLABORATION IT PARENTS AND
SCHOOLS BY STATE OUT CLEAR RULES
IN THE- REGARDING FORMATION SHE
IN THE CURRENT LACK THAT A
TRANSPARENT OPEN AND COLLABORATE
PROCESS OF PUBLIC POLICY
DELIVERY. IF ESSENTIAL
REQUIREMENT ABOUT EFFECT AND THE
LIBERAL. I OR MANDATE TO VOTE
YES ON SB TEN FORTY FIVE AND
SUPPORT CURRENT ALL RIGHT PUBLIC
EDUCATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
DOCTOR WILL ALL RIGHT WE WILL
COME HERE TO ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. PLEASE STATE. YOUR NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL PLEASE. JENNIFER ACTORS
AND REOPEN CAL SCHOOL AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK. SEE NO
ONE ELSE HERE ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED LET'S GO TO THE LINE'S
MADAME MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
WHAT I MEANT ZERO FEAR IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL GO TO TWO
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICK WRONGLY
IN BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WILL LINE ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI THIS IS GABRIELLE INGRAM
YEAH THAT SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE GO. MY TWENTY THREE
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. I. MEXICO
CAROLINA TWO EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS RICK
CAL HOKKIEN I AM FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I REPRESENT CATHOLIC
FAMILIES FOR FREEDOM AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WIND ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY ONE THIRTEEN.
YES BUT. HI MY NAME IS IN ITSELF
A NUMBER OF STAND UP SACRAMENTO
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CALL YOUNG PLASTER COUNTY MOM
FOR LIBERTY CHAPTER CHAIR STRONG
SUPPORTER ITSELF. THANK YOU ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS ALLEY HOLDEN FROM
SAN BENITO COUNTY- WITH ONE
CHILD IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND I FULLY SUPPORT SB
TEN FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU LINE
TO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS THOMAS BECAUSE
WILLIAM AND THE RESIDENTS OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT YOU HAVE A SOME
YOUTH. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD HI
MY NAME IS CINDY BROADHEADS. I
AM A NURSE AND A MOTHER OF TWO
AND PUBLIC SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINES TO SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS THERE'S
BEEN MORE OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ITSELF.
THANK YOU FOR GOOD LINE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S KRISTEN LOPEZ FROM SAN
BERNADINO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE TO TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO-HILLARY CHAVIS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS WORKING IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND PARENTS OF THREE
CHILDREN IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
. IF YOU LINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHIEF. NINE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXAVAR
LINE TO SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARK.
YEAH RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT TO LINE IT TO NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS DESIRING BEING OUR MEMBER OF
AND THAT SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I THREE HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU FOR HEARING US MY NAME
IS TERRY HAD KOBE AND I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA PARENTS
INVOLVED WITH THE CHILDREN IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL SB
TEN FORTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NINE TO EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH GOOD MORNING
JONATHAN ANDERSON FATHER RETURNS
IN THE EAGLE I SUPPORT THIS BILL
. THANK YOU I AM THRILLED TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ALYSSA SONORA WITH LOS ANGELES-
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS UNITED AND
WE STRONGLY STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. IF YOU WANT TO
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. MY NAME IS LIBERTY GAUNTLET
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE CELLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TO NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
DAISY- FROM THE CITY OF
MONTCLAIR AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB TEN FORTY FIVE. PM. THANK YOU
LINE TO SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JENNIFER MORE FEEL AND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
BEFORE AT THREE TEN FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU LINE ONE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY
WHAT NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE ONE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN DO YOU HAVE A SOME
YOU- CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW WE CAN
YES. MY NAME IS JULIE CENTER
STOLEN FROM CHINO VALLEY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU LINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ABOUT
MINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DISCREDITABLE THAT APPROACH IT
WITH EDUCATE ADVOCATE FOR. THANK
YOU ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE SEVENTY SEVENTY YOU
HAVE SOME YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE OF THREE OLD THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING SURE
INSURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS SERENA
LODGE AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT AS
- MELENDEZ FELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A SOME
YOU TO SIXTY SEVEN. LINE TWO
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS UNLIKELY MADDEN AND I
AM STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. AND
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA THREE OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SANDRA
BROWN PARENT OF FIVE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
MANAGER WE HAVE ONE MORE IN Q.
WE WILL GO TO LINE THEM. ONE
MOMENT HERE. LINE THREE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PENNY
HARRINGTON FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MANAGER GREAT
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR OKAY
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE ANY CHAO
LISTED AS OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANY CHAT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB TEN FORTY FIVE WHICH
REQUIRES TEACHERS TO PROVIDE A
COPY OF THEIR LESSONS PLANS
WITHIN THREE DAYS UPON THE
REQUEST OF APPARENT. LESSON
PLANS ARE TOLD THE GUY TO GUY
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION CTA
BELIEVES THAT HE MANDARIN PACE
IN WHICH OF COURSE OF STUDY IS
IMPLEMENTED IN THE CLASS YOU
MUST BE DETERMINED BY THE
INDIVIDUAL. EDUCATORS DO THEIR
BEST PLAN THE COURSES BUT
LESSONS QUICKLY CHANGED BECAUSE
OF UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHETHER BE AN IMMEDIATE HIT IT
WHEN AN EXAM SHOWS A CLASSES
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL- REVIEWING
MATERIAL- LARGER PIVOT TO OF
VIRTUAL. VIRTUAL INSTRUCTION IN
THE MIDST OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
CITY BELIEVE THAT PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT IN EDUCATION
TRANSPARENCY IS CRITICAL. AND
THERE ARE APPROPRIATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT FROM THE STATE LEVEL
TO THE ONLY A LEVEL. THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FAIR FRAMEWORK
STANDARDS CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS. THE CAP
PROCESS IN THE LOCAL PTA. ONE
THE CURRICULUM. MATERIALS ARE
APPROVED IT IS INCUMBENT ON THE
TEACHERS TO IMPLEMENT THEM AND
TEACHERS NEED THE FLEXIBILITY TO
SUCCESSFULLY DELIVER THAT
MATERIAL. CITY BELIEVE THAT IT
IS NOT HELPFUL NOR APPROPRIATE
TO REQUIRE EDUCATORS TO SUPPLY
THE LESSON PLANS. TO PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS UPON REQUEST. HOWEVER
IT IS IMPORTANT INAPPROPRIATE
FOR TEACHERS AND PARENTS DEVELOP
A RELATIONSHIP. BASED ON TRUST
TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF
STUDENTS. MANDATING LESSON PLANS
TO BE TURNED OVER THE SELF AND
THE ABILITY TO BUILD THAT
RELATIONSHIP FOR THESE REASONS.
FIFTIETH RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
TEN FORTY FIVE AM ASX RENOVA.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO ANY ONE HERE IN- UP. PLEASE
STATE YOUR- AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. THE TERM MEMBERS
TIFFANY WALKER WE OF C. OF TWO
WE APOLOGIZE FOR GETTING OUR
LETTER LATE IN ANALYSIS WE JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT TEACHERS
SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON THEIR
CLASS PLANS AND WE APPRECIATE
THIS CONVERSATION BUT DURING THE
STRESSFUL TIME. WE REALLY WOULD
LIKE BELIEVE THAT THE CURRICULUM
AND THE TRANSPARENCY ALREADY
EXISTS AND THAT PARENTS AND
TEACHERS SHOULD REALLY ENGAGED
IN THE CURRENT PROCESS WITH THE
STATE ADOPTION SCHOOL WERE
REFUSED TESTIMONY LIKE HERE AT
THE SCHOOL NIGHTS PARENT
CONFERENCES HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
AND SO MUCH MORE WE CAN FURTHER
THIS WE CAN STRENGTHEN OUR
SCHOOLS. IN THAT PROCESS AS THIS
THE ASSIST GIVE THEM ANY IT'S
JUST BURDENS IN OUR MIND THE
OVERBURDENED TEACHERS WHO WANT
TO SERVE OUR TEACHERS THE BEST
LIKE THOSE THAT WE HEARD FROM
FOLKS AROUND STATE- JUST
REQUIRING A DAILY LESSON PLAN
EVERY DAY IS THAT ONE. IS ONE
MORE BURDEN AND A VERY LARGE
BURDEN ON THOSE ALREADY
OVERWORKED AND UNDERPAID IN MANY
CASES IT PROVIDES NOR
TRANSPARENCY BUT FEELS LIKE AN
ATTEMPT TO CREATE A VERY BETWEEN
TEACHERS AND PARENTS AND
STUDENTS THIS LAW FEELS VERY
TROUBLING TO OUR STAFF AND OUR
MEMBERS BECAUSE IT IS
UNNECESSARY. AND IN FACT CLOSE.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN AS AN A. J. TO
FEEL FOR. MOTIVATE I WANT TO
BURN OUT TEACHERS MORE. WE'RE
NOT SAYING THAT NECESSARILY
SUPPORTERS ARE DOING THAT HERE
BUT IT CAN REALLY FEEL THIS THIS
ENERGY THAT WE WANT TO. HEAD
PARENTS AND TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS AGAINST EACH OTHER AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WANT WE WANT.
SCHOOLS THAT HELP DESK. PROVIDE
BETTER EDUCATION FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED WHO WISHES TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND- OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SEEING NONE MADAM
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE Q. OF
ANYONE ON THE LINES WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FORTY FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
COULD NOT POSITION. WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWO TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS DIRECTION IS KEYFROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE THREE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
I'M NEARLY. YES WE CAN. HI- I'M
I LIKE DO I CALL THEM LIKE I
LIKE TO FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR BOTTOM LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MICHAEL SHERMAN I
HAVE HE DIDN'T AND NUMBER IN A
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE AND THE
HUSBAND OF A- CALIFORNIA TEACHER
AND I AM NOT. IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU LINE TO
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS GABBY REYES. EIGHT
EIGHT MAMA AND I GOT CUT OFF BUT
I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT YOU
HEARD ME STOP FOR. THANK YOU
NEXT THREE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
MY TO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU ABOUT TO LINE
THREE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
- YES I'M HERE COUNTY.
NINE THREE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
HEALTHY ANY AIRLINE IN STUFF
FOR. THE PORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THE MAN CARE WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. AND AS A
REMINDER WE ARE ON THE VISION OF
S. B. TEN FORTY FIVE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. RIGHT
TO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN YES
. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
TEN FORTY FIVE SUPPORT THANK YOU
WE ARE TAKING OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO
LINE THREE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI I CALLED IN LATE BUT
I'M ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF TEN
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR LINE THREE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MARINA I STRONGLY SUPPORT WILL.
AND AS A REMINDER RERUN
OPPOSITION OF AT FEET. TEN FORTY
FIVE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE.
TWO SIXTY SEVEN. TWO SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWO FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME.
WE CAN. HI MY NAME IS SALIM FROM
UPLAND DISTRICT AND ARE PRESENT
A PLAN PARENTS FOR CHANGE AND
FREEDOM AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
S. B. TEN FORTY FIVE. YEAH
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
OKAY LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
DOLLY. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE OFFER FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FOR IT TO MOVE THE BILL. I
KNOW THAT- I BROUGHT A BILL
SIMILAR TO THIS NOT QUITE. LIKE
THIS BUT- I THINK IT'S GREAT FOR
TRANSPARENCY FOR PARENTS TO BE
ABLE TO. ENGAGE IN SPECIALLY
WHEN WE'VE SEEN DISTANCE
LEARNING IN THE BUILDING NOT TO
BE ABLE TO. ACCESS OUR SCHOOLS
AS FREELY AS WE LIKE JUST
BECAUSE OF THE CODE CONCERNS WE
HAD THE PAST SO- LIKE MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU CENTER THE ONLY
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT I WOULD
JUST- THE CITY OF SANTA
MELINDA'S THAT EXISTING LAW DOES
ALREADY ALLOW PARENTS TO
INSPECT. HIGHER CURRICULUM SO I
THINK THAT THEY MET PARENTS DO
HAVE THAT RIGHT I KNOW WHEN MY
GIRLS WERE IN. GRADE SCHOOL AND
ANYTIME I EVER WANTED TO SEE
WHAT THEY WERE LEARNING IT WAS
NEVER A PROBLEM. I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD BUT I
WILL BE VOTING NO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. I WOULD THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND YOU KNOW I JUST.
FIRST I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO CALLED IN OR- OR
CAME TO SUPPORT THE BILL I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH I
THINK- YOU KNOW WE SAW THE
EVIDENCE DAY BY SO MANY PEOPLE
CALLING IN TO SUPPORT THAT THERE
IS A STRONG DESIRE FOR THIS
TRANSPARENCY. AND YOU KNOW- I
HAVE KIDS IN SCHOOL STILL AS
MANY MEMBERS OF. THE DEER AND
WITH. MANY TEACHERS IS EASIER TO
COMMUNICATE IN ASKING AND WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE CLASSROOM BUT
IT'S ALWAYS EASY. FOR EVERYONE-
THE- THERE IS A- WASHINGTON. ABC
POLL THAT SAID 81% OF AMERICANS
BELIEVE PARENTS SHOULD HAVE A
SAY IN WHAT. THEIR CHILD'S
SCHOOL TEACHERS. THIS COINCIDES
WITH THE STATEMENT MADE. BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S SECRETARY
EDUCATE- EDUCATION SECRETARY
ARNE DUNCAN IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
AND HE SAID AND I QUOTE. I WANT
TO HAVE TOO MANY PARENTS
DEMANDING EXCELLENCE IN THEIR
SCHOOLS. I WANT ALL PARENTS TO
BE REAL PARTNERS IN EDUCATION
WITH THEIR CHILDREN'S TEACHERS.
FROM CRADLE TO CAREER WHEN
PARENTS DEMAND CHANGE AND BETTER
OPTIONS FOR THEIR CHILDREN. THEY
BECOME THERE THE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY BACKSTOPS FOR THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. AND HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT AND CLEARLY AN
INTEREST TO BE ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION IN OUR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION SHOULD NOT. BE A
PARTISAN ISSUE BUT I DO WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE THINGS- THAT
THE OPPOSITION BROUGHT UP. THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS NOTED IN THEIR
OPPOSITION LETTER THAT SB TEN
FORTY FIVE MAY ADDITIONALLY
INHIBIT THE ABILITY OF AN
EDUCATOR TO PROVIDE STUDENTS THE
MOST EFFICIENT USE. OF LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AREN'T QUITE TO
THE CONTRARY MEMBERS THE
PANDEMIC ACTUALLY PROVIDED
PARENTS A WINDOW INTO THE
CLASSROOM PERHAPS FOR THE FIRST
TIME. SO THEY CAN SEE EXACTLY
WHAT WAS BEING TAUGHT AND WHAT
THEIR CHILDREN WERE LEARNING.
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL WOOD MISTER
ADMINISTRATORS NOTED IN THEIR
OPPOSITION. THAT PROVIDING
LESSON PLANS TO PERRANCE SOMEHOW
REDUCES THE POWER OF TEACHING BY
RESTRICTING EDUCATORS TO TEACH
THE BOOK AND FURTHER LEAD TO JOB
DISSATISFACTION IN INCREASE THE
SEVERITY OF THE EDUCATOR
SHORTAGE- I FIND THIS HARD TO
BELIEVE BECAUSE EDUCATORS ARE
ALREADY. REQUIRED IN MANY
INSTANCES TO CREATE A LESSON
PLAN IT IS NOT A FURTHER BURDEN
FOR PROVIDING THAT TO PARENTS.
OF TEACHERS ARE ALREADY REQUIRED
TO FOLLOW STATEWIDE CURRICULUM
FORMER UP FRAMEWORK FOLLOWING
THE ASSIGNED TEXTBOOKS SO IF
THEY'RE NOT. THEN WE HAVE A
BIGGER PROBLEM THAN THOSE WHAT
IS BEING ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL.
I'M AND ALSO MANY SHARE WITH YOU
BECAUSE- I AM KIND OF IN THIS
MYSELF RIGHT NOW PERSONALLY WITH
MY KIDS IN SCHOOL. A LOT OF
SCHOOLS ALREADY HAVE IT NOW- AT
MY CHILDREN'S SCHOOL IT'S
CANVASSED IN ART YEAH CAMPUS AN
INFINITE CAMPUS. AND I CAN GO ON
THERE AND I CAN SEE. WHAT GRADES
MY KIDS GOT IF THEY WERE TARDY
IF THEY WERE ABSENT- YOU KNOW
ALL THAT STUFF THEY HATE IT I
LOVE IT AS A PARENT. BUT YOU
KNOW IT I CAN'T QUITE GET IN
THERE IT DEPENDS ON THE TRAINING
OF THE TEACHER BUT I CAN'T QUITE
GET IN THERE TO SEE THE ACTUAL
ASSIGNMENTS THOUGH I WAS FOR
INSTANCE THE OTHER DAY I COULD
PULL UP A QUOTE IS THAT THEY
WERE GIVEN. I'M IN CLASS WHICH
IS TEACHING THEM ABOUT A
LITERACY PASSED THAT USED TO BE
GIVEN I'M IN ORDER FOR- YOU KNOW
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO VOTE AND
THAT WAS. A GOOD FIND FOR ME
BECAUSE THAT WAS SOMETHING WE
COULD FURTHER TALK ABOUT. YOU
KNOW AT HOME- CAN'T FIND THAT
EVER BUT NOT EVERY SCHOOL HAS
THIS AND THIS IS WHAT PARENTS
WANT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT. THESE THNGS THAT
ARE BEING DISCUSSED IN OUR
CLASSROOMS AND- AND WHAT IS
BEING TAUGHT SO I JUST. WANTED
TO POINT THAT OUT THAT- SOME
SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY DOING THIS
ACT FACT MANY SCHOOLS ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS- AND
CERTAINLY PARENTS WOULD
APPRECIATED IF. IF ALL OF THE
SCHOOLS REDOING THIS- SB TEN
FORTY FIVE DOES MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PARENTS TO BE A PARTNER WITH
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ENSURE CHILDREN RECEIVE A
QUALITY EDUCATION- THE FINAL
POINT WAS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND THEY
SAID THAT LESSON PLANS- TOOL TO
GUIDE CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION. AND
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT IS
EXACTLY TRUE SAID GIVING PARENTS
THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT THAT
GUIDE IS HELPFUL TO THE STUDENTS
HELPFUL TO THE TEACHERS AND IT'S
HELPFUL- YOU KNOW TO EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THIS EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS WE ARE NOT. I UNDERSTAND
TEACHERS ARE I FEEL OVERBURDENED
I GET IT BUT- WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR THE MOON AND THE STARS HERE
WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR THE LESSON
PLAN IF SOMETHING CHANGES IN THE
LESSON PLAN. THAT'S PERFECTLY
FINE THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES AND IT'S
TYPICALLY A TEACHERS NOT GOING
TO DO A LESSON PLAN DAY BY DAY
IF THERE. AT ALL TO BE HONEST-
THEY'RE DOING A LESSON PLAN
LIKELY BY THE WEEK SO IT'S NOT
AS THOUGH. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO SIT DOWN AND
WRITE OUT A LESSON PLAN EVERY
TIME THEY MAKE A CHANGE FOR
EVERY. PARENT THAT ASKS FOR IT I
MEAN ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT ALSO
PROVIDES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE FOR TO BE PROVIDED
ELECTRONICALLY SO FOR INSTANCE
IF THE SCHOOL HAS. THE APP LIKE
MY CHILDREN'S SCHOOL DOES THEY
JUST POSTED ON THE APP IT'S EASY
PEASY AND ANY PARENT CAN ACCESS
IT IF THEY CHOOSE TO- SO IT'S
JUST IT'S NOT AN OVER. A BURDEN
SAM REQUEST AND I THINK-
PERHAPS. THOSE WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION- OVERSTATING THE
CONCERNS- WITH THE BILL. IN IT.
FINALLY I. YOU KNOW I'M I'M
READING. THE NEWS ABOUT- THIS.
WAVE OF PARENTAL CONCERN THAT IS
SWEEPING THE NATION NOT JUST
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND THERE
WERE SOME TEACHERS UNION
REPRESENTATIVES WHO. WHO MADE
SOME VERY INFLAMMATORY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE DESIRE OF PARENTS TO
BECOME INVOLVED. IN THEIR
STUDENTS EDUCATION IMPACT ONE
WENT SO FAR AS TO SAY. THAT THIS
IS HOW WARS START. OKAY PARENTS
AREN'T STARTING A WAR IF
ANYTHING IT'S COMMENTS LIKE THAT
IN ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THAT.
DEBTORS DURING THE WAR WITH
PARENTS AND WE WANT. TO TAMP
THAT DOWN WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE.
THE PARTNERSHIP THIS IS. THIS IS
NOT MEANT TO BE A WEDGE BETWEEN
PARENTS AND STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS THIS IS MEANT TO BRING
THEM EVEN CLOSER TOGETHER SO
THAT PARENTS CAN HELP THEIR
CHILDREN WE KNOW FULL WELL. THE
LEARNING LOSS THAT TOOK PLACE
BECAUSE OF CODE IN BECAUSE OF.
YOUR KIDS AND MY KIDS HAVING TO
SIT IN FRONT OF A LAPTOP
COMPUTER ALL DAY LONG- NOT
SEEING THEIR PEERS THEIR
TEACHERS NOT EVEN SEEING THEM
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO
HAVE THEIR CAMERAS ON. THERE IS
A SIGNIFICANT LEARNING LOSS AND
PARENTS REALLY NOW WANT TO BE
MORE INVOLVED NOT ONLY TO CLOSE
THAT GAP BUT THEY GOT. A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS THAT THEY THAT THEY ARE
MORE INVOLVED SO THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE ASKING- IN WITH THAT- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I FELT. THANK YOU
CENTER MELENDEZ AND AYE I WOULD
JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT I DON'T
KNOW THE LAST TIME YOU SIX-
ATTENDED A SCHOOL BOARD MEETING.
BUT I THINK IN PARENT
INVOLVEMENT IS ESSENTIAL BUT
SOMEONE NEEDS TO GIVE SOME OF
THESE PARENTS A LESSON. ON HOW
TO BE PROFESSIONAL YELLING AT
PEOPLE SCREAMING AT PEOPLE
RUNNING UP AND DOWN THE AISLES-
HECKLING PEOPLE AND STUDENTS WHO
ARE SPEAKING. I THINK THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE SO I AGREE WITH YOU
A 100% THAT PARENTS SHOULD
ALWAYS BE INVOLVED. BUT WE
SHOULD BE MODELING GOOD BEHAVIOR
FOR OUR STUDENTS I WOULD. HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR DOLLY MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB TEN
FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA NO. LEYVA NOW- TROUBLED.
COURTESY KELLY HI KELLY I GLAZER
THESE ARE KNOWN MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
NO PANTS NO HAN NOW. THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE RECONSIDERATION I
WOULD THINK YOU'RE VERY WELCOME
ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE SENATOR
PORTANTINO PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE WOULD ESTABLISH A
DISH WASHER GRANT PROGRAM THE
IDEA CAME FROM ENVIRONMENTALISTS
IN MY DISTRICT TO GET A PILOT
PROGRAM IN GLENDALE WHERE THEY
PUT. MODERN DISHWASHERS IN THE
SCHOOL AND SAW THAT IT REDUCE
THE USE OF SINGLE USE WASTE-
THEY MONITORED THE- NUMBER OF
CUSTODIAL- TRIPS TO EMPTY. TRASH
CANS AND SAW THAT THE DISTRICT
WOULD SAVE MONEY AND BE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND BY RE
USING DISHES PLATES AND KNIVES
THIS WOULD CREATE A- PROGRAM SO
DISTRICTS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AROUND THE STATE. COULD RETROFIT
THEIR KITCHENS WITH THESE HIGH
CAPACITY WASHER SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE- WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER PORTANTINO A WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO YOUR LEAD US SUPPORT WE
HAVE TWO FOLKS YUP MONICA
COMPAGNIA AND I BELIEVE SHE IS
CALLING IN AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
ALEXANDER DRINA. CHAVEZ WHO IS
HERE IN PERSON I'M GONNA GO TO
THE IN PERSON PERSON FIRST
ALEXANDRIA PLEASE PROCEED GIVE
TWO MINUTES. I THINK YOU CHEN
MEMBERS I MILLER CHÁVEZ AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. I CALIFORNIA
HAS ITS RELEASE WASTE ISSUE IN
ONE ASPECT OF IT THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED AS THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WASTE THAT SCHOOLS
GENERATE. ACCORDING TO COLOR
CYCLE SCHOOLS UNIVERSITIES
GENERATE OVER FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO THOUSAND TONS OF WASTE EACH
YEAR. IN CALIFORNIA MEANWHILE
CITYWIDE RECYCLING AND DIVERSION
RATES ARE FEELING DUE IN PART TO
THE INCREASED USE OF SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT
RECYCLABLE. NO USE PLASTIC FOOD
WHERE IT'S TYPICALLY MADE OF LOW
QUALITY PLASTIC OR POLYSTYRENE.
THAT CANNOT BE RECYCLED AND
CONSTANTLY CONTAMINATES
RECYCLING AND HAS TO BE DISPOSED
OF AS TRASH. SUPPORTING REDUCES
THE BEST WAY TO MITIGATE SCHOOL
GENERATED WASTE AND- NEW MACHINE
PURCHASES TYPICALLY PAY FOR
THEMSELVES WITHIN EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. BUT SCHOOLS
OPERATING ON VERY LIMITED
BUDGETS AND WITH COMPETING NEEDS
MAY STICK WITH SINGLE USE
SERVICE WHERE SIMPLY DUES TO THE
COSTS OF UP FRONT INVESTMENT. SB
TWO FIFTY FIVE TO HELP SCHOOLS
GET PAST THE INITIAL COST
MANAGEMENT THREE CAN ELIMINATE
THE USE OF SINGLE USE AND WHERE
IN SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT WILL NOT GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR MONICA COMPAGNIA
MONICA PLEASE. PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANKS SHARING CAN BE
MORE. MY NAME IS MONTH COMPLY.
THE NUMBER WITH THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL. AND I CAN TELL AT
FOR. ALLEN MCGUIRE UNIFIED
SCHOOL. WHERE I WAS PREVIOUS A
PARA VOLUNTEER WITH P. GREEN
LINE CAN. WITH THE DOWNEY OF THE
DISH MACHINE YEARS A BY THE FAT
. OUR SCHOOL IS ABLE TO MOVE
FROM JUST. THREE FOR KATHY. THE
DONATION REMOVE THE HIGH UP
FRONT COSTS FOR THE- WHICH WAS
THE MAIN VERY TO AND THE PROBLEM
THAT AFTER TWELVE FIFTY. WILL
FALL OFF. US STARTED BY FIVE THE
- WITH THE OLDER. USED TO LIVE
AS ARE JUST LIKE POSTING CAL.
REMOVE THEM ALL AND NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. THEY THEN MEDIAN.
NEEDED FOR A- WE CAN FIGURE.
SUPPLY OUR DISH. IS OF THE ART
THE HIGH. THAT LETS NOT FIGHT IN
MINUTES. QST FOR YOUR ANALYSIS
WITH THE- INSURER FOR YOU. AFTER
WHICH STATE OF FIVE THOUSAND. IN
MOST FROM NOT HAVING. THE
DEFAULT. WITH FUNDING FROM AS
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE THAT. COULD
COME IN. AND SCHOOL WON'T NEED
TO DECIDE BETWEEN REPLACE. A
FAILING REFER. AND TAX SINGLE
WAVE. IN ADDITION TO MASSIVE WAY
WITHOUT FOR THE DISK DOESN'T
HAVE TO WITH SHORTAGES. RISING
COSTS OF USE ITEMS INSTEAD OF
CHANGE OUT THE TRASH CANS MORE.
PRICE A DAY IN THE LIFE ROOM R.
COSTA. IS ABLE TO FOCUS ON
ORGANIC FORTY. WITH ONLY ONE.
TRASH THAT WE LONGER AWAY
THOUSANDS OF. TRADE YEAR WHICH-
MANY. CHANGES AND QUICKLY FILL
THE GREEN BAY. THE BEST FIFTY
PHONES WEEKLY. WASTE PICKER
REQUIRE NOW BY AND THIRTY EIGHTY
THREE WHICH IS THE- CELESTICA.
INC MORE STATE. WITH LONGER SELL
OVER HUNDRED TENTH. FOUR FOR THE
LAST ANNUALLY I KNOW LOW HAVE TO
COMPETE. PICKUP FELL FORKS
RAPPERS THE BLUE OFF THE TO BEEN
IN THE PLAN. AMOUNTS TO. NO
LONGER.
PRESS OR SUPPORT FOR SB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AT B. FIFTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FEAR IN SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE AT TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY TO SIXTY
SEVENTY YOU HAVE A FROM YOU.
OKAY LINE OF THREE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN CHRISTOPHER CALLING ON
BEHALF ALAMEDA SOFTLY IN HELPING
PROTECT YOUR HIPPOCAMPAL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THREE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING CARE NUMBERS GENEVIEVE
AVEDON ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN
FEES LOBBYING COALITION AND HEAL
THE BAY AND SUPPORT I HAVE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH. IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
THE TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CATHY
SCHAEFER ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FIND REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TWO FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU HAVE A
SOME YOU. AND I'M SURE WE ARE
NOT FOR THIS IMPORTANT KILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PANAMA
WRITER ALL RIGHT WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO ANYONE
HERE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHO
WISHES TO OPPOSE SEEING NO ONE
MADAME MODERATOR BACK TO YOU TO
CUBA ANYONE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE
SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF AT THE
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITE OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR MCGUIRE BUT DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS SEEING AND HEARING
THEM CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAY
CLOSE BY THANK ALL THE ADVOCATES
FOR BRINGING THIS TO MY
ATTENTION RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. METAMODEL
EXCUSE ME MADAM CONSULTANT THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATE
MCGUIRE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE OCHO ABOVE-
TENNESSEE. VALLEY GLAZER GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN ALL
RIGHT HAND ON THAT BILLS OUT BUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO VOTE ALL RIGHT OUR
LAST BILL OF THE DAY A BILL ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE OF TWENTY
NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE SENATE
MCGUIRE WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT
FROM YOUR SEAT VERY GOOD- PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING CHAIR IN GOOD MORNING I
WILL TRUNCATE THE- THE STATEMENT
HERE IS WELL FIRST AND FOREMOST
I WANT TO SEE YOU TOO. LATE HER
WORK ON THIS BILL IN ALONG WITH
HER INCREDIBLE CONSULTANT TEAM A
VERY GRATEFUL UP FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND I ALSO WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO STATE
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRUCIAL ISSUE
AND OF COURSE I'LL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AT
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS YOU KNOW
THAT STUDENTS IN ALL CORNERS A
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLING WITH
PANDEMIC RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH INCREDIBLY TRAUMATIC
TIMES THE PAST TWO YEARS IN
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE OR SEEN
AN INCREASE IN NEED RELATED TO
STUDENTS IN THE SOCIAL.
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING THAT'S WHY
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN AGAIN I'M
GRATEFUL FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
WE'RE INTRODUCING SB TWELVE
TWENTY NINETY TO CRUCIAL BILL L.
STATUS SHOULD PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
TEN THOUSAND GRANTS FOR ASPIRING
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO
COMMIT TO SERVING KIDS IN YOUTH
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
NONPROFITS HERE'S THE BOTTOM
LINE OF THE BILL TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION WOULD FUND TEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL GRANTS
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
EACH TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
GRANT A STUDENT WOULD HAVE TO
RECEIVE. AT WOULD HAVE TO BE A
TO COMMIT TO A MINIMUM OF TWO
YEARS OF SERVICE EITHER IN A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR NONPROFIT
THAT SERVES A SCHOOL DISTRICT
THE BILL TAKES A WORST ALLERGY
IN HERE I MEAN BY THAT AREAS
WHERE THERE IS HIGHER CASES OF
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES OR
A LACK OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WOULD RECEIVE
PRIORITY FUNDING THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WOULD OVERSEE THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE PROGRAM IN
CONSULTATION WITH SUPERINTENDENT
THURMAN IN CALIFORNIA APARTMENT. EDUCATION IN GRANTS WOULD BE-
A FORTY TWO IN THE- WHO WORK
WITH YOU. IN SETTINGS. AT MIDDLE
PROFESSIONALS WHO AGAIN WHO WERE
TRIPPING FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR
NONPROFITS. I IN TO DATE WE HAVE
ON THE PHONE. MADAM CHAIR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
ALSO WANTED MODES THANK YOU TO
CHRISTINE STONER MERTZ. SHE IS
THE CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA LINES
OF CHILD SERVICES WHO'VE BEEN
ABSOLUTELY INSTRUMENTAL IN THIS
LEGISLATION AND BOTH WILL BE
WITH US TELEPHONICALLY TODAY
THANK YOU TO AFFECT THANK YOU
CENTER MCGUIRE ALL RIGHT WILL
GIVE GO TO YOUR LEAD SUPPORT. OF
META MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE A QUEUE UP SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY MISTER THURMOND. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. OF PLEASE BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
TWENTY NINE. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR REQUIRE EMPLOYERS
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP. ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. LIKE ALSO
THANKED THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR OUR CHILDREN FAMILIES UP
WITH THE WORK. WITH US TO
DEVELOP THE CONCEPT. I THINK YOU
HEARD. FROM THE SENATOR. HOW
GREAT THE NEED IS THAT YOU ALL
KNOW WHAT KIDS HAVE BEEN THROUGH
DURING THE PANDEMIC. EVEN THE
BEYOND THE PANDEMIC IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THE TWENTY COUNTY THAT
HAVE HAD FIRES THIS YEAR NOT
THAT STIRS. THE INFALLIBILITY OF
CLINICIANS TO SUPPORT. THE
GROWING NEED FOR MENTAL HEALTH
IT IS GREAT. THIS BILL IS A
CREATIVE IN A STRAIGHTFORWARD
WAY- TO RECTIFY THAT SITUATION
SIMPLY BY PROVIDING. A GRANT OR
SCHOLARSHIP DAY INSPIRING
CLINICIANS. ALL CAPACITY ON THE
HEALTH CAPACITIES- TO BE ABLE TO
HELP. US SPECIFICALLY- THOSE WHO
COMMIT TO WORKING IN SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS- AND GOT IT. TO
HELP US. CLOSE THE GAP THAT BY
MANY. STANDARDS WAS CONSIDERED
TO BE- VIRTUAL MEETING BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC- YOU. CALIFORNIA
WAS ONLY ABLE TO PROVIDE ABOUT
THIRTY PERCENT. OF THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS YOU.
KNOW THAT'S BEEN EXACERBATED. BY
THE PANDEMIC SIMILARLY
CALIFORNIA HAS ALMOST SIX
HUNDRED REGIONS IN THE STATE.
WHERE THERE IS NOT SOMEONE WHERE
THERE'S A ADEQUATE SUPPLY. A
LITTLE HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES TEND TO BE
LARGELY AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO
ASIAN AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER.
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO ADDRESS THAT WORK FOR
SHORTAGE- INTO PROVIDE. FOR THE
FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
IF WE ASK YOUR I. BOATS HONESTLY
ONCE NINE TWELVE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SEA. AMANDA
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE Q. UP MS
STONE ARMOR. MS MERGIA TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU SO MUCH- SURE
LEYVA AND COMMITTING. LIKE TO.
OF CLUBBERS. LEADERS ON THE BILL
YEAH- THE PARTNERSHIP DISCIPLINE
. THURMOND THIS BILL AIMS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL NEED TO EXPAND
AND DIVERSIFY THE MENTAL HEALTH
WORK FOR SERVING THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN YOUTH AND PARTICULARLY
SERVICES. THAT CAN BE SCHOOL
BASED AND SCHOOL LENGTH. R. ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NONPROFIT
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS ARE WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE TO INSURE THAT
WE URGENTLY ADDRESSED. THE
CURRENT MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FOR
CHILDREN YOU. RECENT CDC DATA
SHOWS THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC
ONE IN TEN HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE. AND EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE HAD
EXPERIENCED A SHARP RISE IN THE
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY. AND
BLACK YOU HAVE SUFFERED FAR
WORSE THAN THEIR WHITE PEERS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE EXPERIENCING THIS
VERY REAL MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
THE LACK OF QUALIFIED
PROFESSIONALS IN THE WORKFORCE
CANNOT MEET THE NEEDS. WE MUST
FIND WAYS TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT REFLECT THE CULTURAL
AND LINGUISTIC DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ANSWERED. WORKFORCE
SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE DOES JUST
THAT- SENATOR- ACQUIRE OUTLINES
THE PARAMETERS OF THE BILL. WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING TOGETHER THAT
WE CAN TO BOLSTER AND EXPAND AND
DIVERSIFY THE WORKFORCE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. WE REQUEST
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT ON THIS
CRITICAL AND VIRGINIA TO BUILD
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE WILL
GO TO SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SEEING NO
ONE. ON MEMORY WE'RE GOING BACK
TO YOU FOR ANYONE ON THE LINE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPORT.
OF SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU YOU'RE OF AB TWELVE TWENTY
NINE MAKE ONE AND THEN. GET
MEDICAL ONE IT MEANT FOR YOUR
INSTANT. WE WILL GO TO LINE
THREE FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND IN THE JOHNSON GO WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CONTENT STRONG SUPPORT
SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT TO LINE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TONY
TRIP GUERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
PUPIL PERSONNEL SERVICES TO
EXPAND THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF SB
TWELVE TWENTY NINE AND THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE SPANNING THE
ARTIST'S OFFICE. TO WORK WITH US
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WERE LINE TO TWENTY YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS LAURA
PATTERSON CALLING FROM SYCAMORES
NONPROFIT MENTAL HEALTH AGENCY
AND WE ARE AT THE FOR A FULL
TWENTY. THANK YOU ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANDREA BALL AND A HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS WE HAD A
SUPPORTIVE DEMANDED WITH THE MAN
IS BEING ACCEPTED WILL MOVE TO
FULL SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
LINE OF TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
HILLARY TRAVÉS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SEEING
NO ONE HERE AMANDA MODERATOR
BACK TO YOU CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION
TO. SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION UP AT THE
B. TWELVE TWENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THAT ZERO. AGAIN THAT
IS ONE AND THEN THERE OF YOUR
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IF YOU AT THE TIME
MEDICARE THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR ARE OVER IT BACK
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED SENATE MCGUIRE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. AGAIN MANAGER
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT YOUR STAFF ENGAGEMENT
I WANNA ALSO SAY A BIG THANKS TO
OUR SUPERINTENDENTS SCHOOLS TONY
THURMOND ALONG WITH MR NUMBERS.
AFTER THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE-
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER PAN MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA. HI LEYVA I
WILL TROUBLED. FOR TENNESSEE.
VALLEY LASER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI CAN
I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL OPEN ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WHO ARE ON EDUCATION
COMMITTEE PLEASE COME FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN VOTE ON ALL BILLS.
LET'S FIRST BEFORE WE- GO TO THE
BILLS THAT ARE ALSO LISTED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. I DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR PAN MINNESOTAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT SENATOR
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI- TROUBLE BOGE.
PROTEST THE- DELI. GLAZER GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN
I. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MUCH
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ALRIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
ONE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE.
THE MOTION WE OF THAT'S RIGHT
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE
MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZERS MA'AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
LEYVA HI LEYVA OHIO TROUBLED.
COURTESY SALLY. GLAZER GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN
RIGHT HAND I. BELIEVE THAT BILL
ON CALL MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB NINE
SIXTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING ON A- COURTESY. KELLY
GLAZER GLAZER MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE
AYE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FOR S. B. TEN FORTY
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. TWENTY THREE- YES I DO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS TO FOLLOW
HIM THREE FIRST SB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB ELEVEN FORTY FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING
ONLINE VICE CHAIR VOTING ONLINE
COURTESY. DALY MCGUIRE WHERE I
AM RIGHT LEAVE THAT BILLING CALL
NOW WILL MOVE TO FIVE NUMBER
FOUR SB TEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. TEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING NO VISSCHER HAS NOT
VOTED. OR TELEPHONE. TESSIE.
THAT'S IT OKAY VERY GOOD WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM SIX AS THE
BILL THANK YOU SB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR ROTH ATTEMPT THE BILL
BOYD THE CHAIR NEEDS SOME ICE
TEA OR SOMETHING THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEYVA OHIO TOWBOAT.
COURTESY DALLI DALLI AYE GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
PAN RIGHT HAND I WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL OPEN FOR OUR VICE CHAIR
NUMBER MOOD FILE ITEM SEVEN TO
HAVE OF THE BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN HAS MOVED SB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FIVE
ITEM NUMBERS SB FOURTEEN THIRTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI- TOWBOAT.
COURTESY DALLI. DALLI HI GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
PAN RIGHT HAND I THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED. OR
TELEPHONE. COURTESY DALY. OKAY
VERY GOOD MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B.
TWELVE TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR HAS
NOT VOTED OCHO ABOVE. COURTESY
DALY KELLY I VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE WILL
LEAVE A COUPLE MORE BILLS ON
CALL FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU EDUCATION. YOU GOT IT
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOU. ALL RIGHT SUTTER
DOLLY WHICH ONES DO YOU KNOW.
AND ONE OKAY. OKAY SO START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE CAN
YOU'RE WELCOME ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSENT YOU'RE VOTING
ON A VICE CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED
PATROL BOAT COURTESY DELI DELI I
VERY GOOD OKAY NOW WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM. ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE SURE HAS NOT VOTED A
TROUBLED. CORTEZ THE DELI DELI
NOW. VERY GOOD AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. FIVE RIDERSHIP TO
MEMBER SORRY FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB NINE SIXTY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING NINE
VICE CHAIR VOTING ON AYE
CORTESE. DELI DELI I. WE'RE GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FRANK
APPRECIATED ALL RIGHT WE WILL
WAIT FOR THE WE NEED SENATOR
CORTESE AND SIR OTOBO. TO CLOSE
EVERYTHING OUT. IF YOU. THIS
PACKET RIGHT THAT.
ARMENTA CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSENTS YOUR
VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR HAS NOT
VOTED OCHO ABOVE COURTESY HI
POTENTIALLY I THINK YOU ARE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING AYE VICE CHAIR HAS
NOT VOTED OCHO ABOVE. COURTESY
ALL RIGHT COURTESY I. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB NINE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB NINE
SIXTY FOUR THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE FOR
VOTING NINE COURTESY. PROTECT
THE I. SEVEN ZERO. SEVEN ZERO
THAT WANTS OUT YEAH WE HAVE ONE
DONE OKAY. OF FILE ITEM THREE SB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE S. B. ELEVEN FORTY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING AYE VICE CHAIR
BOARDING I CORTES E. WHAT HAS
THE ITEM. THAT BILL IS OUT SIX
ZERO CORRECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
S. B. TEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB TEN FORTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ARE EXCUSE ME TO
YOUR VOTING NO FRAZIER HAS NOT
VOTED PATROL BOAT. CORTESE NO
CRITTERS ENOUGH RIGHT WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN A FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING AYE VICE CHAIR HAS
NOT VOTED A TOWBOAT. PROTESTING
ALL RIGHT FOR TO THE AYE LET'S
MOVE TO FOLLOW NUMBER SEVEN SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR HAS
NOT VOTED PATROL BOAT CORTEZ A-
PROTEST THE AYE VERY GOOD FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING
NINE VISSCHER HAS NOT VOTED
PHOTO ABOVE CORTES E. ALL RIGHT
CRITICIZED KELLY- RIGHT NEXT.
FINAL ITEM. SB TWO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN FIFTY.
TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIRMAN I
ADVISED HER HAS NOT VOTED PHOTO
ABOVE. BECAUSE THE- FOR TO THE I
THINK YOU CENTER CORTESE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THAT'S
CRAZY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HOPEFULLY HOPEFULLYEVERYTHING'S
CAUGHT UP AT SOME POINT RIGHT.
ASSESSMENT. IT'S NOT VOTER PHOTO
ABOVE THE TROUBLED BY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS- OUT. OF
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING AYE
VICE CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED OTOBO.
FOR TROUBLED NOW. AT THAT BILLS
OUT FIVE TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LET'S MOVE TO FILE ITEM
FOR SB TEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOR SB TEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING NO FRAZIER HAS NOT
VOTED PHOTO ABOVE. YES TROUBLED
BY VERY GOOD THAT BILL FAILS BUT
WE DID GIVE WE WILL GIVE
RECONSIDERATION TO THE AUTHOR OF
FILE ITEM SIX SB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
ELEVEN NINETY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING HI FI SURE IS NOT
VOTED. PATROL BOAT. OR TROUBLED
BY SEVEN SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM
SEVEN SB FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY THREE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VOUCHERS NOT VOTED PHOTO ABOVE
. FOR TROUBLED BY THAT BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO FILE ON NUMBER EIGHT
SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I'D BUY SHARES NOT
VOTED. WHICH VOTE. FOR TROUBLED
BY THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN ZERO SIX
SIX ZERO THANK YOU. OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB TWELVE
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING I BUY SHARES NOT
VOTED. PHOTO ABOVE. A TROUBLED%
BY THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN ZERO ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SENATOR CHOI BOGUE. THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
MUNSON SUGGESTIONS ARE TO US AND
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON.
EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED.